STARTED SUBCOMMITTEE NOTING AN
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
I THIS IS THE AUGUST EIGHTH
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED
FORTY FOUR BILLS TO CONSIDER
THIS MORNING.
WITHOUT REQUEST I WOULD ASK THAT
IF SOMETHING IS GOING TO
SUSPENSE YOU CONSIDER NOT
PRESENTING ON IT.
COURSE YOU CAN [inaudible]
S. CONSIDER --
AND LESS YOU OF COURSE HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO CAME UP JUST TO
PRESENT ON THAT FOR
PRESENTATIONS AT FOR THOSE WHO
HAVEN'T BEEN HERE BEFORE A VERY
STRICT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE. TO
KNOW MORE THAN TWO WITNESSES ON
EACH SIDE FOR TWO MINUTES EACH.
THAT'S THE ROLE YOU WILL GET A
TEN SECOND WARNING AND THEN YOU
WILL BE CUT OFF --
WE APPRECIATE YOU KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO FISCAL ISSUES THIS
IS NOT A POLICY COMMITTEE IT IS
A FISCAL COMMITTEE --
SO I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE A LOT
OF AYE.
IMPORT POLICY CONSIDERATIONS IN
THOSE AYE HOPEFULLY WERE DEALT
WITH IN THE POLICY COMMITTEES
[inaudible]
WITHOUT --
WE WILL GO AHEAD AND START.
BUT LIKE MISTER MONEY WAS FIRST
IN LINE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR I'LL BE
PRESENTING FIRST ON SENATE BILL --
TEN NINETY GOOD MORNING I GOT
HERE FIVE THIRTY TO BE FIRST IN
LINE.
SO LITTLE LATER MAKE YOU ONLY
ADD DON'T HAVE ACQUIRED BUT WHEN
WE DO IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU --
SO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS --
ON JANUARY ELEVENTH OF THIS YEAR
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION APPROVED P. GENIES
REQUEST TO RETIRE DIABLO CANYON.
BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THE LAST
NUCLEAR ENERGY FACILITY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT TO OUR DISAPPOINTMENT DID
NOT APPROVE THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
MITIGATION PROGRAM OR FULLY FUND
THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION PROGRAM
THAT ARE VITAL COMPONENTS TO THE
SUCCESS OF THE PLANTS RETIREMENT.
BOTH OF THESE PROGRAMS WILL
PROVIDE A BRIDGE TO OUR REGION.
TRANSITION TO CLOSURE OF DIABLO
CANYON MOVES FORWARD.
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY
AUTHORIZES THE P. YOU SEE.
APPROVED ELEMENTS OF THE JOINT
PROPOSAL THAT WAS SUBMITTED AS
PART OF THEIR RETIREMENT
APPLICATION.
INCLUDING EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE COMMUNITY IMPACT
MITIGATION PROGRAM WHICH THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS RECOGNIZES --
IT WAS THE P. YOU SEE THAT SAID
THEY DIDN'T BELIEVE THEY HAD THE
AUTHORITY TO PROVE THAT IT
NEEDED LEGISLATION.
THAT IS THIS LEGISLATION.
WELL A REQUIRES THE FULL FUNDING
OF THE EMPLOYEE RETENTION
PROGRAM INJECTS A PC TO MANAGE
pITS INTEGRATED RESOURCE PLAN. TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S NO INCREASE
IN GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS A
RESULT OF THE CLOSURE.
FINALLY THE COMMUNITY HAS
ASSUMED THE PUBLIC SAFETY RISK
FOR THE PAST THIRTY THREE YEARS
WHILE ALL P. JEANNIE CUSTOMERS
HAVE REALIZED THE BENEFITS.
OVER THE PAST SEVERAL DECADES.
COMMUNITY INCLUDING STAKEHOLDERS
TO REPRESENT LABOR ENVIRONMENTAL
COMMUNITY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
SCHOOL DISTRICTS EMPI GENIE HAVE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME NEGOTIATING
THIS JOINT PROPOSAL.
A MADAM CHAIR APPRECIATE YOUR
RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE SOME
WITNESSES TO TESTIFY BUT FIRST
I'D LIKE TO INVITE OUR MY
COAUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
WOULD SIMPLY ECHO THE SENATOR'S
COMMENTS.
EVERY WORD OF THEM THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE CONSIDERATION
AND JUST KNOW THAT THIS THIS IS
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
THE WORKERS AT DIABLO.
WHO WORK HARD EVERYDAY UNDER?
THE HIGHEST SECURITY YOU CAN
IMAGINE BY KEEPING THIS PLANT
SAFE AN OPERATIONAL AND IT'S
ALSO VERY IMPORTANT BILL FOR
STATES --
ENERGY SUPPLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CAROLING ABOVE OF THE SAN LUIS
OBISPO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WHO ARE SO THANKFUL
TO THE DELEGATION FOR WORKING SO
COLLABORATIVELY TO BRING THIS
BILL.
AFFORD JUST ONE EMPHASIZE IT IS
A TIME LIMITED MEASURE THIS IS
NOT A FOREVER A FUNDING STREAM
THAT WILL GIVE THE COUNTY AND
THAT SUB JURISDICTIONS
OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE. FOR A
VERY SIGNIFICANT CHANGE IN THE
ECONOMIC ACTIVITY IN THE COUNTY
THAT IS DERIVED FROM THE PLANT'S
RESCUE FOR I'VE ATTAINED THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
RICHARD ARMEY HERE BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF PEOPLE BEACH ELECT ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES.
AND I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
LEGISLATORS WERE KINDS
LEGISLATION FORCES HERE
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SENATOR MEMBERS TAKE A POSSIBLE
HAVE A ST LOUIS COASTAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT THANK YOU.
FOR ALLOWING SOMETIME WERE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE PAUL GONZALEZ
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ATASCADERO WE LIKE TO THINK
THE SITTER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
AND WE ASK YOUR ABOUT.
TREES A PRIVILEGE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I'M A NOTE FOR THE
FUTURE THIS WAS FINE BECAUSE
YOUR WITNESSES WERE VERY SHORT
THAT THE LAST WOMAN DID IT
CORRECTLY SO AFTER THE TWO
WITNESSES --
JUST AYE AYE I JUST DON'T WANT
TO BE HERE ALL DAY --
WE'RE GOING TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE JUST REGISTER THEIR
SUPPORT BY SAYING THEIR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION WITH THEIR WITH AND
THEIR POSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING TO TELL ME ASSURE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OF FINANCE OPPOSES THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT THE
ECONOMIC IMPACTS WILL BE GIVEN
THAT THE ASSESSMENT WHICH WILL
INCLUDE REVIEW OF THE POTENTIAL
OPTIONS FOR THE STATE AND LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO CONSIDER.
IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THE ADVERSE
IMPACT OF THE SHUTDOWN WILL NOT
BE FINALIZED UNTIL THE END OF
THE CALENDAR YEAR.
THANK YOU.
SEEN OF MISTER VERA THANK YOU
MEDICARE'S SCRAPES YOU
BIPARTISAN EFFORT ON SUCH
IMPORTANT ISSUE WHERE SIMILAR
ISSUE WHERE I AM AND SENATE BILL.
FOR WOULD HAVE THIS KIND HEADS
UP YOU GOT A TEN YEAR HEADS UP
THAT PLANT WAS GONNA DE
COMMISSION.
UP SO I WOULD JUST ADVISE YOU TO
STAY ON THIS BECAUSE WE'RE STILL
DEALING WITH THE A LAWSUIT
EMPLOYEES THE WASTE IT'S BEING
STORED ON SITE.
SO OBVIOUS I'D LOVE TO WORK WITH
YOU ON SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS
WHICH I CLOSE ON THIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR APPRECIATE
YOUR AYE RECOMMENDATION
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURROWING --
WE WILL CONTINUE WORKING IN A
BIPARTISAN MANNER RICHARD AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE NOW PRESENT ON S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY SIX AND ALSO
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM WHICH
IT LOOKS LIKE WE MAY.
HAVE [inaudible]
A CHEAT.
MA'AM SECRETARY CAN YOU CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
PRESENT BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
AUTORUN [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHAO.
FONG.
FRIEDMAN.
GALLAGHER.
GARCIA [inaudible]
IS IRAN.
OBERNOLTE YOUR QUIRK HERE REYES.
MOVE THE BELL.
WAS THAT A MOTION I'M SORRY ON
TWELVE THIRTY SIX OR WAS THAT A
MOTION ON TEN NINETY THIS ONE
THAT HE'S A THE PREVIOUS BILL.
OKAY SO NOW WE HAVE A THINK YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER
QUIRK IN A SECOND BY MISS CREEL
ON SP.
TEN NINETY A WARY OF STILL THAT
THAT BILL WILL BE ON CALL.
AND MR AHMADI WILL NOW PRESENT.
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY SIX WE HAVE
A MOTION.
BUT THE MOVE BY MISTER QUIRK AND
A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO YOU MAY
PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CURRENT LAW REQUIRES ANY
CALIFORNIAN WHO WANTS TO DRIVE A
LARGE TRUCK.
PASSENGER BUS OR OTHER
COMMERCIAL VEHICLE TO FIRST
OBTAIN A COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S
LICENSE BY SIMPLY PASSING A
WRITTEN TEST AND A SHORT BEHIND
THE WHEEL DRIVING.
TEST ADMINISTERED BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
THERE IS NO EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT APPLICANTS FOR
A COMMERCIAL DRIVER'S LICENSE
RECEIVED ANY INSTRUCTIONAL
TRAINING.
OR EVEN COMPLETE A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF HOURS OF TRAINING
BEHIND THE WHEEL OF A LARGE
TRUCK.
THE CASE WAS BROUGHT TO US BY A
CONSTITUENT THE MOTHER OF A
YOUNG MAN WHO LOST HIS LIFE ON
HIGHWAY.
SEVENTEEN WHEN IN.
TRUCK DRIVER ILL EQUIPPED ILL
TRAINED RAN HIS.
TRUCK INTO TEN VEHICLES KILLING
TWENTY FIVE YEAR OLD --
DANIEL SENATE BILL TWENTY THIRTY
SIX TWELVE THIRTY SIX WERE
REQUIRE THE DMV TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO COMPLY WITHTHE
NEW FEDERAL RULE ESTABLISHED
LAST YEAR BY THE FEDERAL MOTOR
CARRIER SAFETY ADMINISTRATION.
THAT WILL INSTITUTE NEW MINIMUM
TRAINING STANDARDS FOR ALL ENTRY
LEVEL COMMERCIAL DRIVERS IN ALL
ADDITIONAL ESTABLISH A MINIMUM
NUMBER OF HOURS OF BEHIND THE
WHEEL TRAINING.
AS THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS
POINTS OUT THE BILL WILL HAVE A
MINOR FISCAL IMPACT ON THE DMV
AS THE DEPARTMENT IS ALREADY
PREPARING TO IMPLEMENT THE NEW
FEDERALLY REQUIRED RULE.
MEMBERS IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT WE
ACT NOW SURE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMERCIAL DRIVERS ARE RECEIVING
ADEQUATE TRAINING BEFORE BEING
LICENSE TO SHARE THE ROADS WITH
THEIR FAMILIES AND CONSTITUENTS.
BY SUPPORTING SENATE BILL TWELVE
THIRTY SIX TODAY YOU'LL BE
HELPING US TO TAKE THAT FIRST
CRITICAL STEP.
THE BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AT
THIS POINT THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
WOULD LIKE PERCENT WITNESS IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS CONRAD PRESENTING THE
OWNER OPERATOR INDEPENDENT
DRIVERS ASSOCIATION OR WHAT
ALLIED OUT AND WE'RE THAT
REPRESENT THE INDEPENDENT
TRUCKERS OVER HUNTER SIXTY
THOUSAND NATIONWIDE OVER SIX
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA.
WE SUPPORT THIS POLICY WE'VE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED --
BEHIND THE WHEEL TRAINING AND
FURTHER INSTRUCTION --
AND ON THE FISCAL WE DO THINK
THAT THIS WILL HELP SAVE COSTS --
FOR CAMPBELL VEHICLE ACCIDENTS
FOR THE TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHERE JARED
MODE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
SCENE NINE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
FINANCES AND TRONG STILL.
THANK YOU SEE NO QUESTIONS WHICH
ARE CLOSE ABOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THANK YOU WE HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND BUT WE NEED
PLACE AN ICON TO WE GET SOME
MORE MEMBERS HERE.
THANK YOU SIR [inaudible]
SENATOR HILL.
SENATOR HILL YOU HAVE --
QUITE A FEW BILLS BUT THE ONE
THAT ACTUALLY NEEDS A VOTE TODAY.
I'M SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE I ASSUME
YOU'RE PRESENTING ON FIRST.
IMAGE MADAM CHAIR I AM
PRESENTING ON THAT OF BILL AND
DISTILLATE YOU MY WITNESS WHO
WILL BE HERE TESTIFYING ON SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL ALSO BE FOR IF
AGREEABLE.
ALLOWABLE WILL SPEAKER S. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE IN HER
COMMENTS AND THEN I WILL WAIT
PRESENTATION ON S. B..
FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE GREAT THANK
YOU.
SB SEVEN TWENTY ONE THIS BILL
REQUIRES THAT APARTMENT
BUILDINGS THAT ARE THREE STORIES
ARE HIGHER HAVE 15% OF THEIR
BALCONIES EXPECT INSPECTED EVERY
SIX YEARS THIS IS A SERIOUS
ISSUE.
THAT IS KILL PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
THE STATE IF ANY WHO'VE GONE ON
THE LEGISLATIVE TRIP TO IRELAND
IN RECENT YEARS YOU'VE LIKELY
MET WITH THE FAMILY.
CHILDREN WERE KILLED WHEN ABOUT
MOVE LIKE THEM PERSONALLY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OR FOR
FASHION I VOTED YOU HAVE
WITNESSES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES PLEASE.
I'LL MAKE THIS QUICK AS POSSIBLE.
EVEN DOGS TRY TALK ABOUT THE TWO
BILLS TOGETHER.
MANY MISS JACKIE DOWN WHO AND MY
LIFE IS CHANGED FOREVER JUNE.
SIXTEEN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WHEN I LOST MY DAUGHTER ASHLEY.
MY NIECE OLIVIA.
WHEN THE BALCONY THERE STUNNED
MONK COLLAPSED?
MANY OF YOU HERE OF CHILDREN.
AND MANY DO YOU EVER THINK TO
TELL YOUR KIDS DON'T STEP OUT ON
THE BALCONY.
BECAUSE NOT MILLION YEARS I
NEVER TALK TO MY DAUGHTER NOT TO
WALK OUT ON THE BALCONY.
AND THE GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS A COULD COLLAPSE.
BECAUSE WE FAILED THESE KIDS
THREE YEARS AGO BY LETTING THIS
HAPPEN.
THE MANY MILESTONES INNER KIDS
LIFES I'M SURE YOU ALL HAVE THEM --
I DON'T HEARING MONDAY.
HURT TWENTY FIRST WILL BE THIS
WEEKEND BUT A COUSIN GAVIN.
LIBYA'S BROTHERS WILL BE NEXT
WEEKEND THEN NOW BOTH ARE ONLY
REMAINING KIDS WHAT THE LIFT
THAT'S OUR LIFE WITH OTHE
SIBLINGS.
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN UNDER YOUR
COLLEGE AGE KIDS ON THE BALCONY
THAT NICE SO THINK ABOUT IT WAS
YOUR KIDS.
THE PARENTS OF THE FIVE VICTIMS
WERE KILLED WE NEVER GET TO SEE
THEIR KIDS AGAIN YARIS PARENTS
ATTEND FEAST SONS AND DAUGHTERS
TO DO YOU S. FOR J. ONE SUMMER
EXPERIENCE.
I CALIFORNIA SEND FIVE COFFINS
BACK HOME.
THAT THE KIDS HOME IN THE COFFIN
IMAGINE IF YOU'RE YOU SEND YOUR
KIDS AWAY TO IRELAND AND THEY
WERE SENT BACK IN THE COFFIN.
THE SEVEN HUNDRED INJURED KIDS
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME HOUSES OF
LIFE'S BEING CHANGED.
SO REALLY THIS BILL REQUIRED
BALCONIES BE INSPECTED UNDER
SAFE AND UP TO COAT.
HER SEE FOR ME I'D LIKE TO SEE
ALL BUCK MUST BE INSPECTED NOT
JUST DEPARTMENTS WANTED.
BUT I WANT THINK IT WAS A MEMBER
OF YOUR FAMILY.
HOW MANY MORE BALCONIES ARE
READY TO FALL DOWN?
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS FROM
BERKELEY LITTLE BERKELEY WHEN
THEY ACTIONS BACK TO TWO
THOUSAND BALCONIES UP TO
BERKELEY COLLAPSE I'M NEARLY ONE
IN FIVE ISSUES.
THIS DATA SHOULD CONCERN YOU --
THAT REALLY REALLY CONCERNS ME
THE WAY THE INDUSTRY DOESN'T
WANT -- TO
WANT REFORM.
HERE ARE THE SIX PHOTOGRAPHS OF
THESE KIDS IN FRONT TO YOU.
THIS IS ALL THE PARENTS HAD LEFT
THERE'S NO MORE MILESTONES FOR
US.
NO COLLEGE GRADUATIONS NO
WEDDINGS NO BABY SHOWERS BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT THEY ALL HAD BIG
FUNERALS.
MY HUSBAND GEORGE NEVER GOT TO
WALKER DAUGHTER THE ODD BUT HE
DID CARRY A COFFIN AT THE AYE
AND A BELOVED COUSIN ALLEVIATE
FOLLOW TURN HER COFFIN NOT IS A
BRIGHT NIGHT SHE BECAME BEHIND
HER COFFIN.
SO I'M SPEAKING OUT TODAY IN
HONOR.
OF THOSE WHO NO LONGER HAVE A
VOICE AND IF YOU BURKE FOREVER.
TWENTY ONE MY NIECE OWN CULLIGAN
FOREVER TWENTY ONE NICK AYE
SHOES TO FOREVER TWENTY ONE LOW
CAMILLA FRAPH TWENTY ONE EMAIL
WANTS.
FOR TWENTY ONE A MY DAUGHTER WHO
JUST TURNED TWENTY TWO MY
BELOVED ACTUALLY.
I URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND MAKE IT HAPPEN BECAUSE THINK
ABOUT IT IN THIS DAY AND AGE AND
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD CALIFORNIA'S LIVE WITH
WILD FIRES AND EARTHQUAKES.
AND THE THIRD THE BIG ONE COMMON
YET CALIFORNIA BUILD CANTILEVER
BALCONIES FIFTY FEET UP ABOVE
GROUND LEVEL MAKE SOMEONE.
WRAPPED IN STOCKHOLM WITH NO
TIES BACK TO THE BUILDING.
THEY NEVER HAVE TO INSPECT OUR
INSPECT THEM AND THEY THINK THEY
CAN LAST A LIFETIME.
SO EVERY TIME YOU WALK UP IN THE
BALCONY THINK ABOUT THESE KIDS
THAT NICE.
AT THIS FUNKY BEEN INSPECTED BY
A LICENSED CONTRACTOR A KIDS
COULD BE ALIVE TODAY GUYS.
SO HOPEFULLY WHEN YOU TAKE A
STEP ON THE BALCONY WILL BE OUR
LAST ACT.
AND IN YOUR SUPPORT YOU'LL SEE
BLACKROCK THE PROPERTY OWNERS
AND WASTE ARE THE PROPERTY
MANAGERS THE TIME --
HAD LETTERS OF SUPPORT THEY ARE
IMPLEMENTING CHANGES.
SO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME FOR
HEARING ME ON THIS.
I DON'T A QUICK I JUST MOVE FAST
I KNOW IS OF A MILLION BILLS
TODAY AND I APPRECIATE YOU HEARD
MY TIME.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY HARD FOR ME
TO KEEP COMING UP HERE AND SEE
MY DAUGHTER SAY HERE WITH ME.
IT'S KILLING ME.
BUT I MEAN WITH THE OTHER ONE
THAT'S GOING TO SUSPEND PUBLIC
THINGS JUST TRY AMBER NAM.
WEEK WILK YOU CAN STAY RIGHT
THERE WE'RE GONNA.
BRING UP THAT BILL NEXT SO YOU
CAN COMMENT ON THAT OKAY SIDE I
JUST DON'T YEAH HAVE YOU COMMENT
ON THAT BILL DURING THIS TELL
STATEMENT ABOUT MY TWENTY ONE SO
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY.
EVA TWENTY I DON'T DAUGHTER NOW
I AND I IN AND FOR THAT REASON
WE OBVIOUSLY GAVE YOU ADDITIONAL
TIME AMID TAKE THAT IS YOUR
SUPPORTERS ARE BODY ELSE CAN ADD
ON ITS RETAIL.
IF A MOTION AND A SECOND.
FISCAL AND LEARNS CONSUL GENERAL
TO WEST UNITED STATES AND WE'RE
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THE
ARTICLE.
I THINK HIM ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
BUT LIZ ROOTED --
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS SEVEN TWENTY ONE
BUT I THINK YOU THINK YOU.
DEBBIE NELSON --
FRIEND AND FAMILY ABOUT.
THE DONAHOE'S IN THE BIRTH
FAMILY AND GET YOUR SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MY CHEN THAT'S THE CONTRACTORS
STATE LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING MARK OLSON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AS OF THE SEVEN THREE VERSION WE
KNOW THIS BILL HAS NO FISCAL
IMPACT ON STATE.
AYE WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF THANK YOU.
LIVE IN MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK A
SECOND BY MR PEROT AND MR WOULD
YOU LIKE.
TO RESPECTFULLY AFTER I GOT
MARRIED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR OBERNOLTE
VOTING NOW.
AT THIS POINT SINCE YOU'VE
WITNESSED UP HERE ANYWAY IF YOU
WOULD LIKE. TO MOVE.
TO DID YOU SAY SBFOURTEEN SIXTY
FIVE FOURTEEN SIXTY FIVE WILL
TAKE THAT TESTIMONY NOW.
IS A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE GOING TO
LET AND HEAD MISTER HILL JUST
INTRODUCED THE BILL AND THEN.
AND THEN BY ALL MEANS.
MOHAWK IT IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE REQUIRED THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
TO STUDY WHETHER OR NOT THEY
WOULD BENEFIT FROM RECEIVING
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS SETTLEMENTS
FROM THEIR LICENSEES.
THIS BILL IMPLEMENTS THIS A
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
RECOMMENDATION BY REQUIRING
CONTRACTORS TO REPORT
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS SETTLEMENTS
OVER ONE MILLION DOLLARS
INVOLVING RENTAL MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS TO TO THE C. SLP.
THE COMPANY THEY CONSTRUCTED THE
BALCONY BECAUSE APARTMENT
COMPLEX WITH ABOUT THE COLLAPSED.
IN BERKELEY IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
SAKE WE CONSTRUCTION HAD PAID
TWENTY SIX AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS IN CONSTRUCTION DEFECT
LAWSUIT.
SETTLEMENTS IN THE THREE YEARS
BEFORE THE COLLAPSED.
IN THIS YEAR'S SHELBY DID NOT
KNOW ABOUT THIS PATTERN AND
PRACTICE OF DEFECTIVE WORK
BECAUSE CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE CONTRACTORS TO REPORT
SUCH SETTLEMENTS.
AT THE TIME THE INTO THE CSW XIN
FORCE WHEN SHE SAID THAT HAD THE
BOARD KNOWN WE WOULD HAVE
ABSOLUTELY TAKEN ACTION SUCH
KNOWLEDGE WOULD HAVE TRIGGERED
AN INVESTIGATION.
WITH THIS BILL THAT WILL HAPPEN
IN THE FUTURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
AND I'VE OF VENDORS AND I DO
HAVE A WITNESS.
OKAY AND I WILL MAKE THIS FAST
SO YOU I DON'T GIVE IT A
BACKGROUND JUST A COUPLE THINGS --
200-015-2000 SIXTEEN LEGISLATION
SESSION --
THE BUILDINGS HE SPENT ABOUT
THREE MILLION LOBBY IN A
MEASURES INCLUDE SP FOUR SIXTY
FIVE SO WAS CENTER WAS TAKEN OUT
THE REPORT PARKS AND FOR STUDY
THE CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD.
GREAT PEOPLE CONDUCT LIKE ABOARD
I TRY TO WORK WITH AND HELP THEM
OUT.
AND GIVE ME AS MUCH INFORMATION
AS POSSIBLE THAT I COULD COME UP
WHICH IT WASN'T FOR STUDY TO SEE
IF THE ABILITY OF THE BOARD TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC WOULD BE
ENHANCE.
BY REGULATIONS REQUIRING
LICENSEES TO REPORT JUDGMENTS
ARBITRATION AWARDS ARE SEGMENT
PAYMENTS OF THOSE CLAIMS
[inaudible]
STUDY.
SO THAT'S HOW I CAME BACK HERE
HOW DO PEOPLE LIVING ABOUT ME
SAID NO THEIR SEX ALL YOUR
BALCONIES.
BECAUSE IF THE STUDENTS HAVE
BEEN KNOWN THAT THESE BALCONIES
WERE BUILT BY SEGWAY.
AND THAT'S LIKELY BEEN REPEATED
THE SUIT TO HONESTLY THINK THEY
WOULD WALK DOWN THE HALL CAN
THAT NIGHT.
WOULD YOU WALK OUT BALCONY VENUE
THAT COMPANY WAS SUED FOR TWENTY
SIX MILLION.
YOU PROBABLY UNDER THE SAME KIND
OF WATER INTRUSION YOU WOULDN'T
DO US -- THE
OTHER THING IS AS JERRY HAD
MENTIONED S. B. FORM FOR SIXTY
FIVE IS MUCH NARROWER THAN SELF
REPORTING AND ENSURE REPORTING
LAWS THAT AND THE OTHER LICENSEE
TRADE AND PROFESSIONAL.
THROUGH IMPORTANT IS ONE MILLION
THAT'S ALL IT IS AND APPLIES
ONLY TO MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
STRUCTURES THE HOTELS COLLEGES
SINGLE FOUND HOMES ARE NOT
INCLUDED --
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT WIRE
ENGINEERS AND ARCHITECTS A
QUADRUPLE JUDGMENT SETTLEMENTS
IN ARBITRATION AWARD BUT NOT THE
LICENSES CONTRACTORS WHO BUILD
WHAT THE ENGINEERS IN DESIGN.
AND THE ARCHITECTS DESIGN.
SO IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
MY UNDERSTANDING AFTER A LOT OF
RESEARCH FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
IS THE PROTECTION OF THE PUBLIC
IS REQUIRED TO BE THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY FOR THE CONTRACTORS
LICENSING BOARD AND EXERCISING
ITS LICENSING.
REGULATORY AND DISPARITY
FUNCTION.
HOW CAN THE CONTRACTORS LICENSE
BOARD DO THEIR JOB AND PROTECT
THE PUBLIC IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE TOOLS?
THEY CURRENTLY RECEIVE ABOUT
FIFTEEN THOUSAND CONSUMER
COMPLAINTS PER YEAR MOSTLY
SINGLE FAMILY RELATED BUT THEY
DON'T GET MUCH A MULTI FAMILY
DWELLINGS SINCE THEY SETTLE.
THEIR PICK OF THE INSURANCE TAKE
THE PAYMENTS TO THE CONTRACTORS
BOARD NEVER FIND OUT ABOUT THIS.
SO AS A MOTHER.
IS THE CONTRACTORSLICENSE BOARD
IN CALIFORNIA ONLY FOR SINGLE
FAMILY HOMES SO IF YOU BUILD A
FENCE AND IT'S OFF A BIT OUT.
ARE YOU CAN BE TOLD TO KNOCK
DOWN ARE DO WHATEVER TUITION
PAYER FINDS BUT THE BIG BOYS THE
LIKE A SEGWAY IN ALL. OH NO
THEIR INSURANCE PAID THE TWENTY
SIX MEDINA NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT IT
THE CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD
DON'T EVEN KNOW ABOUT IT THAT'S
WHAT HAPPENED IN BERKELEY.
THE REASON THE INDUSTRY DOES NOT
WANT THESE REFORMS TO GO TRUE
SOME.
IF THEY CAN DO SECRET
SETTLEMENTS AND HEIGHT.
THEY'RE NEGLIGENT CONSTRUCTION
WHEN THE COPS GET CALL IT REALLY
SADDENS ME WHEN GROUPS OPPOSED
THESE BILLS THAT CAN PREVENT
MAJOR INDUSTRY OUR DEBT. FOR ME
AFTER LOOKING AT SO MUCH DATA I
THINK THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
SHOULD WANT TO REPRESENT A SAFE
INDUSTRY.
AND STOP HIDING BEHIND BADCOCK
CONNECTORS AND THAT THE
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD --
GET RID OF BAD ACTORS BY AROUND
SENTIMENTS FROM INSURANCE OUR
CONTRACTORS TO BE FORWARD TO THE
CONTRACTORS LICENSE BOARD SO WE
CAN PROTECT THE PUBLIC.
BY DOING A CONFIDENTIAL
INVESTIGATION TO DETERMINE IF
THE CONTRACTOR IS COMPLYING WITH
BUILDING CODE REQUIREMENTS.
IF THIS WAS YOUR CHILD ARE
MEMBER OF YOUR FAMILY.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL?
LIKE IT ANYMORE BALCONIES ARE
GOING TO FALL DOWN.
SO REALLY FOR THESE KIDS HERE I
URGE YOU. TO REALLY THINK ABOUT
THIS WHY IS THE COUNTRY'S THOSE
MORE TO BUSINESS IS A JUST PRINT
THING THE FAMILY HOMES AND THE
SMALL PEOPLE.
CONTRACTORS BUT ALL THE BIG BOYS
GET OFF BECAUSE INSURANCE DON'T
HAVE TO REPORTERS BECAUSE IT HAD
BEEN REPORTED.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT SAID WAIT.
IF SOMEONE ELSE ADDED ON THE
RIGHT PAYING.
OUR KIDS COULD BE ALIVE TODAY
GUYS.
I KNOW IT'S NOT YOUR KIDS YOU'LL
WALK OUT HERE AND OF THE OVER
FOR ME.
I LIVED HELD THE LAST THREE
YEARS.
AND THAT'S WHY GUYS I'M GOING NO
WHERE I'M GOING TO KEEP COMING
UP HERE UNTIL EVERYONE DOES WHAT
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO DO AND I
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS HERE CAN
YEAH.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
COMPLETE.
GET THIS STRAIGHT [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ARE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS I'M
SORRY TO REGISTER YOUR SUPPORT.
A VERY THERE'S ONE YET AS YES
VOTERS.
OR INDULGE IN SUPPORT OF WHICH I
CAN THINK ADDITIONAL STRUCTURES.
MY JANET HE CONTRACTORS STATE
LICENSE BOARD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ARE THE SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
PROBABLY SMART.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. ONE IS IS
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL SMART.
TO ALRIGHT --
I SEE NO QUESTIONS THIS BILL
GOES TO SUSPENSE I DO.
AS A MOM I WANT TO THANK YOU I
AM.
PRETTY STRICT ON TIME GUIDELINE
I I'M SORRY BUT BUT I I'M A MOM
FIRST SO THANK YOU FOR USING
THIS TRAGEDY TO HELP MAKE
CALIFORNIA A SAFER FOR ALL OF US
THANK YOU GUYS [inaudible]
RIGHT.
MR HEALTH GIVE ANOTHER ROUND.
OF THE SHOULD BE SENATE BILL.
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT THE LAST
REAL THAT I WILL.
PRESENT I DO HAVE WITNESSES WHO
CAME UP CAME A FARCE BILL ALSO
GOES ON SUSPENSE.
SO WE'RE GONNA MAKE IT SNAPPY IS
AND ALWAYS WILL.
SP.
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT IS THE
PATIENT'S RIGHT TO KNOW ACT OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IT REQUIRES A
PHYSICIAN'S DISCIPLINE BY THE
REGULATORY BOARD FOR THE
FOLLOWING FOUR CATEGORIES OF
MISCONDUCT WILL HAVE TO NOTIFY
THEIR PAIN.
PATIENTS PRIOR TO THEIR VISIT
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT WITH THE
PATIENT DRUG ABUSE THAT CAN HARM
PATIENTS CRIMINAL CONVICTION
INVOLVING HARM TO PATIENTS AND
INAPPROPRIATE PRESCRIBING
RESULTING IN PATIENT HARM.
I WILL END WITH THAT THEM AT OF
CHAIR AND ALLOW ME WITNESSES TO
MAKE SOME BRIEF STATEMENTS THANK
YOU THANK YOU KNOW AND NOT WILL
HAVE TWO MINUTES EACH.
GOOD MORNING TOTAL FOUR MINUTES
AND SPORT.
THINK YOU GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S
AUDRY OF SIGUR.
TURNING IN THE VENTURA COUNTY
JUST TRAINS OFFICE I RUN THE SEX
CRIMES DIVISION ONE SUPERVISOR
OF THAT DIVISION OF TWENTY
LAWYERS.
I AM A U. S. C. LOCK GRADUATE.
IN MY FIRST YEAR OF LAW SCHOOL I
SAW DOCTOR TYNDALL.
BUT HE SEXUALLY ABUSED ME.
AS A WOMAN UNDERGOING A
GYNECOLOGICAL EXAM WHY WOULDN'T
I TRUST MY DOCTOR.
I WAS PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE.
WHICH DOCTOR JINGLE NEW I
TRUSTED HIM.
AND HE USED HIS POSITION OF
POWER TO ORDER THE NURSE OUT OF
THE ROOM.
AND SEXUALLY ABUSED ME.
DECADES LATER I FIND OUT THAT I
WAS NOT ALONE.
THE DOCTOR TYNDALE WAS SEXUALLY
ABUSING WOMAN FOR MANY YEARS HE
IS A PROLIFIC PREDATOR.
PERHAPS ONE OF THE MOST PROLIFIC
SEXUAL PREDATORS IN OUR
GENERATION.
THE INSTITUTIONS WERE CHARGED
WITH PROTECTING US FAILED.
THE TRUST PATIENTS PUT IN THEIR
DOCTORS PROPERLY [inaudible]
FAILED.
AND IT CREATED A SAFE HARBOR FOR
HIM TO CONTINUE HIS ABUSE.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THE
PATIENTS ARE PROPERLY PROTECTED
AND ALSO THAT.
GOOD DOCTORS.
YOU DON'T OF THESE PATIENTS
ARCHITECT.
REMOVING THE REAL SECRECY WILL
HELP ALL OF US.
AND I THINK IT WILL HELP
DISCOURAGE PREDATORS FROM
FINDING A MEDICAL DEGREE AND
HIDING BEHIND A WHITE COATS THEY
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OTHERS.
THE COST INSTITUTIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS.
OF NOT TELLING PATIENTS THAT
SOMEONE'S BEEN CONVICTED OR
FOUND TO BE A PREDATOR BY THEIR
ASSOCIATION.
IS HIGH.
I HAVE NO IDEA HOW MANY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE DEPARTMENT
ALREADY PAID TO INVESTIGATE
DOCTOR TYNDALL I KNOW THEY'RE
FLYING ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
INTERVIEW A WOMAN LIKE ME.
AND THE LA DA HAS ALSO GONE HAVE
EXCEPTIONALLY HIGH COST AS THEY
INVESTIGATE THE CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION. FOR ADDITIONAL
COSTS TO THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
IN THE MENTAL HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW HERE
SEXUAL ABUSE SURVIVORS.
UNDERGO YEARS AND YEARS OF NEEDS.
SO I INVITE YOU TO JOIN ME TO
LIFT THE VEIL PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITY FROM SEXUAL OFFENDERS
TO HIDE BEHIND A WHITE CAT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SUPPORTER.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS GINA AND
TIME A FORMER JIM THIS A TWO
TIME WORLD CHAMPIONSHIPS YOU
MEMBER.
A THREE TIME NC DOUBLE A
NATIONAL CHAMPION AND A SURVIVOR
OF SEXUAL ASSAULT BY MY DOCTOR.
THE DOCTOR THAT ABUSE ME WAS A
CHILD AS A CHILD WAS PROTECTED
BY MANY POWERFUL PEOPLE.
BECAUSE THESE POWERFUL PEOPLE
IGNORED THE WARNING SIGNS AND
REPORTS OVER THREE HUNDRED WOMEN
AND GIRLS HAD MUST JUST STRENGTH
TO STAND UP TO STOP IT.
IT SHOULD NEVER COME TO THAT WE
AS A SOCIETY SHOULD DO BETTER.
THIS IS WHY MEANS FULL SUPPORT
OF SB ONE FOUR FOUR EIGHT
TRANSPARENCY IS VITAL.
WHEN SECRECY IS ALLOWED AROUND
MISCONDUCT OF ANY KIND IS THEN
WHEN PERPETRATORS GAIN THE
CONFIDENCE IN THEIR ACTIONS AND
CONTINUE TO ABUSE?
HAVE A HARD TIME UNDERSTANDING
WHY THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION HAS SO MANY ISSUES
WITH THIS BILL. ONE IS DOING THE
RIGHT THING EVER BEEN WRONG.
I FEEL LIKE IF THEY WANT TO
MAINTAIN THE PUBLIC'S CONFIDENCE
IN THE MEDICAL AND MEDICAL
PROFESSIONALS THEN THEY WILL
STOP FIGHTING AGAINST THIS BILL.
LET'S PUT PEOPLE SAFETY FIRST
AND NOT THE REPUTATION OF
POTENTIAL PREDATORS IF THAT
ISN'T IMPORTANT ENOUGH.
NO THAT THE PASSING OF THIS BILL
WILL SAVE THE STATE MONEY AND
TIME TO PROSECUTE ANYMORE.
WRONGDOING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
YES MY NAME IS LUCY CHIEF I WAS
A MEDICAL OR ASSISTANT
ADMINISTAFF YOU I'M SORRY AT
THIS POINT YOU NEED TO JUST SAY
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OPPOSE
THE BILL.
OKAY MY NAME IS THIS ICHI --
I SUPPORT THE S. B..
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT THINK HIM.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE THOMAS LOPEZ FORMER
MICHIGAN STATE SOFTBALL PLAYER
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL THINK
HIM.
JENNIFER SOMOS OF THE MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEE NOT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE HAVE NO FILE ON THIS BILL.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WHICH YOU
LIKE CLOTHES JEFFREY AFTER
ARRIVAL WHEN THIS COMES OFF
SUSPENSE.
I THINK THERE'S A SENATOR HEALTH
FOR INDULGING ME IT'S ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU.
I SEE NEXT --
DOCTOR P. ON DOCTOR PM LOOKS
LIKE YOU HAVE A FEW BILLS YES
AND I AM WAVING AT THE
PRESENTATION AND ALL THE BILL'S
GOING TO SUSPENSE THANK YOU I DO
APPRECIATE THAT WILL START
THOUGH WITH YOUR DO PASS --
BILLS IT LOOKS LIKE WE'RE GONNA
START WITH SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
YES.
SO THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF SB ELEVEN SIXTY TO
THE DISTRICT BILL THAT REMOVES A
STATE MANDATED HEIGHT
RESTRICTION OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
FEET FOR HALF A BLOCK MARYSVILLE.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
A SECOND BY A MYSTERIOUS.
ALRIGHT WELL AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THERE'S NO COST TO THE STATE AND
THE EYEWITNESSES HERE BURGESS
THERE I GUESS.
MANY ANSWER QUESTIONS SUMMIT
YEAH ME TO ANSWER QUESTIONS AMY
BROWN I MAY HAVE OF PRESLEY
HOMES ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GREAT ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCES NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT I'VE
IT THAT GETS OUT IN ANY ROLL
CALL WITH MISTER OBERNOLTE NOT
VOTING THANK YOU DOCTOR PAN.
MOVING ON TO SB ELEVEN SIXTY SIX
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I THANK YOU.
MOTION BY MYSTERIOUS IN A SECOND
BY A DOCTOR QUIRK.
WHICH IS BRIEFLY SAY AYE
ESCULENTUS AT THE SIX REQUIRES I
CALPERS CONTRACTING AGENCY
NOTIFIED ACTIVE RETIRED CALPERS
MEMBERS WITHIN THIRTY DAYS OF
THE AGENCIES DELINQUENT MAKING
REQUIRED PLAYER CONTRIBUTIONS TO
CALPERS EXPECT WE ASK WHEN I
DON'T.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
AND SUPPORT.
DO WE HAVE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU CAN DON'T GET FROM THERE YOU
CAN COME UP JUST BE REAL BRIEF --
WE'RE WE'RE THIS GUY DON'T
GIVENS CALIFORNIA SPECIAL
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OPPOSES
LEGISLATION.
AYE THIS WOULD REQUIRE --
AGENCIES WHO WERE NOT COMPLYING
WITH THEIR CALPERS REQUIREMENTS
TO THEN SOMEHOW START COMPLYING.
WITH NEW CALPERS REQUIREMENTS I
WOULD THINK IT'S BACKWARDS AS
FAR AS NOTIFICATION.
PICK THE NOTIFICATION SHOULD
COME FROM CALPERS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ANY DISARM [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCES OPPOSE OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT DUPLICATES A PROCESS
ALREADY PERFORMED BY CALPERS AND
COULD RESULT IN ANNUAL COST OF
UP TO TEN MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE DOCTOR
PAM HI YES I WOULD DOES SPEC WE
DISAGREE WITHOUT FINANCE HOWEVER
I WOULD ALSO MAKE NOTE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT --
IF AN AGENCY IS NOT MAKING THE
REQUIRED CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
THEY'RE RETIRE YOU SHOULD KNOW
ABOUT IT SO THAT THE RETIREES
CAN ACTUALLY TAKE SOME ACTION.
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE
RETIREMENT MAY NOW BE AT RISK SO
I'VE TYPICALLY ASK WHAT I THINK
YOU.
I APPRECIATE THAT --
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE TO PUT THAT
ON CALL UNTIL WE GET A FEW MORE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HERE BUT WE DO
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND AND I I
THINK YOU FOR EVERYTHING THAT
REPORT BELLFLOWER RIGHT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEXT UP WE HAVE S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY TWO IS IT YES IT ENJOYS A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HERE --
TO PLEASE PRESENT SP TWELVE
FIFTY TWO THAT ENSURES THAT ARE
WORKING REAL.
THANK YOU THAT ALL WORK WITH A
MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK AND A
SECOND BY MYSTERIOUS.
ALRIGHT ADVENTURES AT ALL
WORKERS HAVE THE ABILITY TO
ACCESS TO PAYMENT INFORMATION
AND RECORDS --
THIS IS --
BY MAKING A SLIGHT CHANGE
EXISTING WALL TO GIVE WORKERS
RIGHT TO INSPECTOR RECEIVED A
COPY OF PAYMENT RECORDS THE
LEGISLATURE CAN PREVENT --
HARMFUL ACTIONS THAT HAVE
OCCURRED IN THE PAST --
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE MIGHT YOU HAVE
WITNESSES.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS MARK
SHOCKLEY CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION SPONSORS
OF THE BILL OF THE BILL MAKES A
VERY SIMPLE CHANGE THAT ALL
AVOID CONFUSION INCOME AND
CONFLICTS IN THE FUTURE ABOUT
WORKERS ACCESS TO ITEMIZE PAY
STUBS AND OF THE STATUTE WE ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS VERY BROAD
AND SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
UNITED HERE THE TEAMSTERS AND
MACHINISTS
MATILDE WORKERS LONG SHORT.
AND NOW THE METRIC.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
SCENE NINE ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE AND A PART OF FINANCE.
WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE TO PROMOTE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES WITHOUT
CUTTING THE COST STATE.
GREAT I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE CLOSE DOCTOR PAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I TAKE IT
OUT ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR PEROT
IN MISTER FONG NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU --
NEXT WE HAVE S. B. FORTINO EIGHT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS S. B. FORTINO IT MAKES
TO CHANGES TO THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY CODE OUT FURTHER PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S FROM NON FIRE SAFE
CIGARETTES.
OUT SINCE THE TO NOTIFY US EACH.
EMOTION BUT AFTER QUIRK IN A
SECOND BY MISS REYES ALRIGHT
WELTS OF TWO THOUSAND FIVE
CIGARETTES SOLD IN OUR STATE
HAVE BEEN REQUIRED TO MEET
CERTAIN FIRE SAFE IGNITION
STANDARDS THIS BILL MAKES
TECHNICAL CHANGES.
OF THAT NATURE AT THAT DEEMS NON
FIRE SAFE CIGARETTES IS
CONTRABAND PER SE AND ALSO
ELIMINATES A LOOPHOLE THAT
ALLOWS NINE FIVE STATES WHO GETS
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
I EXPECT WE ASK HIM AYE VOTE AND
I HAVE WITNESSES TO SUPPORT FROM
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PAN MORNING MADAM CHAIR --
MEDICAID GEORGE FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S A SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL --
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND ARE HERE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE
THINKING.
CURRENTLY SENIOR SYSTEM ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
OF THE CHARGE OF THE TOBACCO
LITIGATION SECTION WITH US FOR A
LIVE OF THANK YOU RATHER DISMAL
SUPPORTERS.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
FINANCE NOTES THAT THIS BILL HAS
NO FISCAL IMPACT ON THE STATE
AND OPPOSES NO REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATED COSTS ON LOCAL
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE DR PRICE IF
WE ASK FOR NIGHT LET'S THINK
UNITED ON A ROLL CALL WITH MR
PEROT NOT VOTING TO MISTER
OBERNOLTE VOTING NOW.
THANK YOU IN IT LOOKS LIKE YOU
HAVE ONE LAST ALL S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
OKAY THANK YOU EMOTION BY
MISTRESS IN A SECOND BY DOCTOR
QUIRK ALRIGHT WELL SP FOURTEEN
TWENTY FOUR ADDRESS ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ESTABLISH AN ADVISORY
GROUP TO STUDY THE PROBLEM OF
THE SPREAD OF FALSE INFORMATION
THROUGH INTERNET PLACE.
BASED SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS AND
DRAFT THIS MODEL STRATEGIC PLAN
FOR SUCH WEAPONS MEDICAID SPREAD
FALSE INFORMATION OR PLATFORMS --
CERTAINLY WE'VE SEEN NUMEROUS
NEWS REPORTS AND EVEN
CONGRESSIONAL HEARINGS ON THAT
SHOW THAT SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORM
SIDE HAVE BEEN USED TO SPREAD
FALSE INFORMATION AND THAT
THAT'S VERY IN.
IMPORTANT WE UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
IS HAPPENING --
SPEAK FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR
EFFORT TO TRY TO HELP US CRAFT A
SOUND PUBLIC POLICY TO ADDRESS
THIS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE THAT
CAN IT DEL IMPACT OUR DEMOCRACY
IN OUR SOCIETY EXPECT WE ASK
WHAT I'VE IT.
THANK YOU AND SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
PARTNER FINANCE [inaudible]
NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE EXPECT WE ASK FOR
DIVERT HEART WE'RE GONNA PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL AND GET A FEW
MORE MEMBERS HERE THAT'S MY NOTE
TO A FEW MEMBERS TO PLEASE COME
AT LEAST --
TO CHECK IN.
WE ARE MISS SCENE I HAVE MISTER
BONTA MISTER CALDERON MISS EIGHT
MEN MISTER GARCIA MISTER
NECESSARY AND THAT WOULD BE
GREAT FOR A FEW OF YOU TO COME
BY THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR VAN GREAT
RESERVATIONS THANK YOU.
JURORS SENATOR ABOUT.
SENATE BILL I SEE YOU HAVE --
NUMBER OF BILLS THAT TAY MANY ON
CONSENT SUSPENSE.
YOU WANNA START WITH SP.
TWO FIFTEEN IT ENJOYS DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE'LL START THE WELL GOOD
MORNING.
MOTION BY MISTER OBERNOLTE IN A
SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
AND I AM SORRY MISTER RIGOLETTO.
IF THEY DON'T GET READY
OBERNOLTE IS NAME AND I'M SORRY
VICE CHAIR BIGELOW HAS MOVED TO
THE BILL --
INDUCTOR CRICKET SECOND --
REESE RESPECTFULLY REQUESTS.
THINK IT THANK YOU SENATOR VELDA
WE HAVE WELL DO WE HAVE --
PORTER'S SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
BRIAN ARE GOING BEHALF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JOHN IS SITTING ON BEHALF OF THE
ALAMEDA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN HON DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHERE NO FILE?
THANK YOU I SEE NO QUESTIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER
ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I THINK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU --
THAT'S WILL.
I SEE A LOT OF SUSPENSE AND
CONSENT CALLAHAN AT LAW --
IF I IF I CAN.
GET THE SUPPORT.
FOR PRESENTING --
SP.
TEN TEN AND TEN NINETEEN ONLY
THAT'S A ARE YOU I ABSOLUTELY.
SO QUICKLY AND WE HAVE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR BILLS ON THE
FINAL TODAY SO WE ASK THAT
SUSPENSE CANDIDATES MOVE QUICKLY
BUT THINGS YOU KNOW.
WILL START WHEN OUR LAST WEEK
TEN TEN TEN IS SO --
AS MEMBERS KNOW --
WERE RECEIVED WERE RECIDIVISM IT --
REDUCE RISEN REQUIRES PROVIDING
HEALTHCARE HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS OF OR
ON PAROLE --
THE INTEGRATED SERVICES FOR
MENTALLY ILL PAROLEES PROGRAMS.
WE ESTABLISHED THAT AND TWENTY
EIGHT ó SEVEN TWENTY AWAY.
AND IT HAS ONGOING FUNDING OF
THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
IT'S IN THE BUDGET.
AND OF WHICH TEN POINT FIVE
MILLION IS SPENT ON MENTAL
HEALTH.
SERVICES.
NOW SINCE THAT TIME --
THE MEDICO EXPANSION PROGRAM WAS
APPROVED THE AFFORDABLE CARE ACT
WHICH ALLOWED SINGLE CHILDLESS
ADULTS TO RECEIVE MEDICAL.
THE CALIFORNIA SIGNED UP
LITERALLY MILLIONS OF PEOPLE.
ADDITIONALLY IN THE MEDICARE
PROGRAM [inaudible]
INCLUDING --
PEOPLE THAT WERE ELIGIBLE --
SUCH AS THESE PAROLEES.
SO NOW --
SINCE THAT TIME THEY'RE ELIGIBLE
FOR MEDI CAL BUT THIS PROGRAM
[inaudible]
STILL FUNDS --
THE MEDICAL NEEDS OF THESE
[inaudible]
PAROLEES.
WITH A 100% GENERAL FUND.
AND DOES NOT USE MEDI CAL AT ALL
TO FUND --
THESE PROGRAMS ASSEMBLY THIS
BILL WITH THIS BILL SIMPLY DOES
IS A SIMPLE THING [inaudible]
SIMPLY ALLOWS.
THE THE THE AGREEMENTS BETWEEN.
THE MEDI CAL.
A MENTAL HEALTH PROVIDERS THAT
THE COUNTY OR SOME KIND OF
COUNTY OR OF A PROVIDER.
THAT'S WORKING WITH THE COUNTIES.
YOU PROVIDE MEDICAL CARE.
AND USE META CAL [inaudible]
RATHER THAN.
A 100% GENERAL FUND.
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS IS A SIMPLICITY
THING NOW IT SAVES.
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
OF THE STATE JOURNAL FUND.
SO -- URGING
A VOTE ON THIS AND AT THE PROPER
TIME [inaudible]
WHEN --
YOU'RE LIFTING IT FROM SUSPENSE
I'D LIKE CONSIDERATION THAT.
AND I DO HAVE SOME I DON'T HAVE
TO PASS AMOUNT NOW BUT I DO HAVE
SOME.
CHARTS THAT IDENTIFY.
COUNTIES THAT RECEIVED THIS
FUNDS.
AND HOW MUCH SAVINGS THEY WOULD
RECEIVE IF.
THEY WERE ABLE TO USE MEDI CAL
TO PROVIDE CARE FOR THESE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
AND WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SPEAKER SINCE PART
GOOD MORNING I AM MARRIED THERE
WITH COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE
ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
MEASURE SENATOR BALLOT THINK
MADE ALL THE FINANCIAL POINTS
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT
THAT IT'S A GENERAL FUND.
SHIFT IN ORDER TO LEVERAGE UP
290% FEDERAL FUNDS UNDER THE
AFFORDABLE CARE ACT IN THAT OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS BETWEEN
THREE MILLION AND FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS HAS REVERTED TO THE
GENERAL FUND.
FAILING TO SERVE THESE GROW
LEASE WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS SO WE URGE REMOVAL
FROM THE SUSPENSE FILE NEXT WEEK
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SHARON REPORT WITH
THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING SIMPLY PUT S. B. TEN TEN
THAT WOULD A SHIFT DOLLARS TO
MAKE THE PROGRAM THAT IT FUNDS
MORE AFFECTED.
BY INVESTING IN EVIDENCE BASED
INTERVENTIONS THE UCLA STUDY OF
THE CURRENT PROGRAM FOUND THAT
THAT PROGRAM WAS INEFFECTIVE IN
ACHIEVING THE GOALS OF REDUCING
RECIDIVISM --
AND AS SENATOR FELL AND MS ADAIR
POINTED OUT IT ALSO IS VERY
COSTLY TO THE STATE.
AYE IF THE LEGISLATURE'S SHIFTED
IS MEANT RESOURCES.
TOWARD COUNTY BASED MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FOR MEDI CAL
THE STATE WOULD SAVE OVER SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS AND RECEIVING
FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENT FOR MEDI
CAL.
IN DOING SO REDUCE THE MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT COSTS FOR
PAROLE THE PARTICIPANTS BY OVER
TWO THIRDS --
MULTIPLE STUDIES SHOW THAT THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE PROGRAM
WOULD MAKE AND BOTH MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND HOUSING ARE
EVIDENCE BASED.
AND HAVE BEEN PROVEN TO REDUCE
RECIDIVISM --
SO WE DO BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROGRAM THIS BILL IS REALLY
TRYING TO MAKE THIS PROGRAM MORE
EFFECTIVE WHILE ALSO SAVING THE
STATE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
MAR PAROLEES PROCESS.
I THEREFORE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
AND HOUSING SPELL OFFICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
BRIAN HUNDRED AND A HALF THE
NATIONAL ALLIANCE ON MENTAL
ILLNESS CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CHRIS MARTIN ON BEHALF OF POLICY
WE CAN HOUSING CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WHAT WE THINK OR WHAT THE
AUTHORS GOAL OF FINDING WAYS TO
MAXIMIZE FEDERAL REIMBURSEMENTS
FOR PEARLY MENTAL HEALTH CARE?
HOW WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
PRIMARILY FOR THE FOLLOWING
REASONS ON THE BILL INCLUDES
COSTS THAT AREN'T INCLUDE IN THE
MINISTRIES AND SPENDING PLAN?
WE ESTIMATE THE COST OF
SUPPORTING THE HOUSING PILOT
PROGRAM COULD REACH IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
FROM THE GENERAL FUND.
SECOND WE KNOW THE CDC ARE AS
LIKELY TO FACE DIFFICULTY
FINDING.
COUNTIES WILLING TO ENTER INTO
AMMO USE AND LASTLY WERE OPPOSED
TO THE REQUIREMENT TO CDC ARE
PAVE THE NON FEDERAL SHARE THE
COST FOR PAROLEES PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM INCLUDING THOSE
ENROLLED IN MEDICAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NOW QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE SENATOR BREAUX GOT --
TO ANSWERING QUESTIONS THAT WERE
RAISED BY THE PARLIAMENT.
WE HAVE THE COUNTY TESTIFYING
HERE.
SAY THEY SUPPORT THE BILL SO IF
THE BILL PASSES OBVIOUSLY THE
COUNTIES ARE GOING TO BE
INTERESTED THAT'S NUMBER.
ONE NUMBER --
TWO IF YOU LOOK AT THE COUNTY
WAS A COUNTY INTERESTED KNOWS.
WELL I I I'VE I'VE SERVED TWELVE
YEARS HERE IN TWELVE YEARS AS A
COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
AND THE COUNTIES INTERESTED
BECAUSE IF THE PEOPLE GO TO
COUNTY -- IN
THERE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AT THE COUNTY LEVEL.
IT'S A 100% COUNTY GENERAL FUND.
NOT MEDI CAL SO IT DOESN'T
REALLY MAKE ANY SENSE --
TO NOT TRY TO ACHIEVE MEDI CAL.
FOR THESE INDIVIDUALS.
AND THE LAWS NOW ALLOWING IT AND
WE SHOULD ENCOURAGE IT AND NOW
IT'S A SAVINGS TO THE STATE.
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL MONEY IN THE BUDGET.
THAT'S A THE THE OTHER THING I
WOULD SAY IT WOULD NOT.
WE'RE JUST SUPPOSING THAT A
SHIFTING OF THE PINK.
THINK YOU AND YOU WANT TO MAKE A
PRESENTATION THAT I'M SORRY THAT
BILL DOES GO TO SPEND FILE.
YOU ALSO MIGHT MAKE PRESENTATION
ON S. B. TEN NINETEEN WHICH IS
ALSO MOVING TO SUSPENSE WHICH
LIKE I START THAT YOU'LL DO THAT.
ARE APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ON THIS
BILL THIS IS --
A CANDIDATE FOR SUSPENSE AND
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE US --
AT THE PROPER TIME THE
COMMITTEES WILL WILL CONSIDER
THIS.
OF THIS IS S. B. --
TEN NINETEEN IT REQUIRES --
NO HEALTH SERVICES OUCH TRIAGE
DOLLARS --
WHICH ARE NOT GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS TO BE ALLOCATED YOUTH --
MALE HEALTH SERVICES SO IT WILL
SPUR PARTNERSHIPS.
BETWEEN COUNTIES AND LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL.
AGENCIES TO PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO SCHOOL
CHILDREN'S.
SIMPLY PUT WE'RE TRYING TO GET
JOBS.
MAIL HELP SERVICES FUNDED --
IN -- WITH
THE MALE HEALTH SERVICES ACTS AS
THE MAIN SOURCE.
ARE IN IN SCHOOLS [inaudible]
THAT'S THE GOAL.
IF YOU THINK THAT'S A GOOD IDEA
THIS IS A GOOD WAY TO DO IT --
WE HAVE SUPPORT FROM THE NO
HEALTH SERVICES ACT COMMISSION
WE HAVE THE SECOND DRUG YOUR
TEST I'LL LET HIM SPEAK.
I THINK YOU SPEAKER SINCE PARK
MARIJAN MEMBERS TO BE DOING I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
WITH THE SPONSOR OF THE BILL --
VERY QUICKLY I WOULD SAY THAT
WE'VE HEARD STORIES OF YOUNG
CHILDREN --
SUFFERING THAT HEALTH CRISIS IN
A SCHOOL ENVIRONMENT AND OFTEN
THE RESPONSES TO CALL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HAND CUT THESE
CHILDREN.
AND TRANSPORTED TO THE OFFICE TO
TO S. ARMY EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
TO DEVELOP PARTNERSHIPS WITH
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH WHERE
THEY'RE PUTTING MENTAL HEALTH
WORKERS INTO THE SCHOOLS. TO TO
PREVENT THESE CRISIS FROM
LEADING TO THAT KIND OF A
SITUATION WE SEE THIS AS AN
OPPORTUNITY ACTUALLY REDUCE LONG
TERM COST TO THE STATE AND
COUNTIES OR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EITHER ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
DANIEL MAILLET CALIFORNIA LYING
TO CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES IN
SUPPORT.
CAN BERWICK SENECA FAMILY OF
AGENCIES MELANIE COUNTY BOARD OF
EDUCATION AND STRONG SUPPORT.
I HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER PERCENT
NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
KATHY SUNDERLAND WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU'RE BORN CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
NURSES ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NOT DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE TO RUN IN THE HIS OF
EDUCATION ESTIMATES IT'LL COST A
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND ANNUALLY
TO COORDINATE WITH THE MENTAL
HEALTH.
SERVICES OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION AFTER
THE SEVERAL CEMENT AND
COORDINATION ON THE TRIO'S GRANT
PROCESS I WILL THESE ACTIVITIES
WOULD BE INAPPROPRIATE USE OF
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE FUNDS.
AYE WE KNOW TO THE EXTENT THAT
THERE ARE INSUFFICIENT FUNDS ON
THESE ONGOING COSTS WOULD BE
BORNE BY THE GENERAL FUND.
NOW WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
COMMISSION WOULD RESULT AND
MODERN OF SOCIAL COSTS.
THANK YOU SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
YES -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'RE I'VE BEEN
INFORMED THAT THE MOBILE
SERVICES AT MISTER FUNDS COULD
UP ACCOMPLISH THE FUNDING FOR
THOSE.
THANK YOU LINK YOUR PRESENTATION
SENATOR BILL THIS WILL BE MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AND WE HAVE ENOUGH MEMBERS HERE
NOW TO DISPENSE OF A NUMBER OF
BILLS ON PREVIOUSLY ON CALL.
S. B. TEN NINETY MY MISTER MONEY --
GETS OUT WITH REPUBLICANS NOT
BUILD VOTING MISTER OBERNOLTE
THIRTY NOW.
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY SIX MISTER
MONNING --
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL SB
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX DOCTOR PAN GETS
OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY FOUR DOCTOR PAN
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL.
WITH THAT WE WERE GONNA MOVE ON
TO SENATOR BRADFORD WHO WELL BE
ONLY PRESENT TEEN ON HIS BILLS
THAT ENJOY A I DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WE APPRECIATE THAT S. B. ELEVEN
THIRTY FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WILL BE STARTING
WITHOUT.
ONE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS --
SP ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE DISC
CODIFIES AND ARE MOVING UNVEILED
A GREAT ASSISTANCE PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO THE CARE PROGRAM
RESPECT LAST YEAR I THINK YOU WE
HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR CREEK
WITHOUT A SECOND BY MISS EGGMAN --
ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
I MEAN.
NOT THAT IS A BURGER* ON
BEHALF OF THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE P. C. ESTIMATES NOTICE OR
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL
AS IT CONTINUES THE PROGRAM ARE
IN.
THANK YOU KNOW QUESTIONS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ARE AS STATED TO CSUS OF SIMPLE
MEASURE THAT ALLOWS FAMILIES TO
REDUCE YOUR ELECTRIC OUR RATE
SIMILAR TO THE CARE PROGRAM THAT
ALLOWS NOW UP 218% DISCOUNT ON
THEIR OWN UTILITY BILL RESPECT
AFTER AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND THAT IT'S OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
BRADFORD YOU HAVE ONE MORE BUILT
PRESENT IT LOOKS LIKE SP
FOURTEEN TWELVE THAT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU ANNA S. B..
FOURTEEN A TWELVE JUST CLARIFIES
WHAT A POOR.
SETBACK BACKGROUND
INVESTIGATIONS AS YOUR AS
RELATES TO EXPUNGEMENT OF
CONVICTIONS WHEN SEEKING
EMPLOYMENT I THINK IT ADDS A
GREAT DEAL TO HELP FOLKS WHO
HAVE HAD.
A CHALLENGE IN YOUR LIFE FIND
EMPLOYMENT IN THE BAKING
INSTITUTION I RESPECT LAST RIGHT
VOTE TODAY I HAVE OFF.
HAUSER HERS HERE ARE FROM THE
REENTRY PROGRAM TO TEST FIND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THAT HAS A
MOTION BY MISS RANSOM A SECOND
BY DOCTOR QUIRK.
CAN HEAR ME NOW --
AND IT'S A I SAW THAT ANALYSIS
IT'S A NET.
KIND IN NEUTRAL FISCAL ANALYSIS
WHICH I KNOW IS YOUR CONCERN
TODAY I'M HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS AS YOU WELL KNOW IT IS
A VERY IN THE WE YEAH I
TECHNICAL FIX BUT OTHER THAN
THAT I'M HERE TO SUPPORT THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AND INTERNET QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO KNOW
BECAUSE IT SAYS UP THERE
DIFFERENT BILL THIS IS S. B..
FOURTEEN TWELVE SO I DON'T KNOW.
NO WHICH WE HAD ALREADY PASSED
OUT SB ELEVEN THIRTY FIVE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE NOT.
I DON'T KNOW THERE SOME RULES.
THEN WE GOTTA KNOW WHAT BILL
WERE ON AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY SUPPORT ANY OTHER
SUPPORTERS.
SEEING NONE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEM OUT.
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTINA'S BAGNOLI
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION OUT WE DID SEND IN
OPPOSE LETTER BUT WE'RE IN THE
MIDDLE OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
SENATOR THAT REALLY HAVE NOTHING
TO DO WITH THE FISCAL.
ON THE BILL AND SO I'M I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME --
BUT WE DON'T HAVE ANY FURTHER.
WE CONTINUE TO BE OPPOSED UNTIL --
UNTIL THOSE NEGOTIATIONS ARE
WORKED OUT WHICH WE'RE HOPEFUL
ABOUT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
BUT THIS IS A NEW TRONG EXPLODE
I AM SORRY THERE APPARENTLY I
MISSED SOME OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING LURKERS A MAP OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION ECHOING CHRISTINE'S
COMMENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
AND WE ARE GONNA TRY I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF WITH CAMERAS
AND STUFF A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE
ROOM BUT IF PEOPLE COULD KIND OF
BEYOND IT BECAUSE WE'RE AND TRY
TO MOVE FAST OR SOME OF THESE --
THING WITNESSES NEUTRON THIS
BILL THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A
QUESTION BY A DOCTOR QUIRK.
YEAH IT'S TIME I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE BANKER'S OBJECTIONS TO THIS
AND I AM CONCERNED ABOUT BANKING
THAT'S JUST AN INDUSTRY WHICH
WHAT YOU REALLY HAVE TO BE VERY
CAREFUL BECAUSE THE STAKES ARE
SO HIGH THANK YOU [inaudible]
OF I'D LIKE TO RESPOND THAT --
I'M SURE WOULD YOU WOULD YOU
LIKE A WITNESS RIGHT AYE HUNTS.
AYE I DIDN'T TO PREEMPT AND THAT
THAT'S OKAY I YOU KNOW RIGHT.
SENATE ARE THOUGH OBJECTIONS OF
STATE OR NOT FISCAL ADDED --
PERTAINS TO THIS COMMITTEE OF
THE FILL IT IT EXPOSES THEM TO
FEDERAL --
VIOLATIONS OF LAWS WHICH IS NOT
THE CASE WITH EXEMPTED OF THIS
BILL WOULD NOT PREEMPT A FEDERAL
LAWS AND AT THIS STAGE.
TO THEIR ABILITY TO CHECK
BACKGROUNDS ON EMPLOYEES BEFORE
THEY ARE.
THANK YOU I'M HEARING FROM DR
CORRECT THAT HE'S VOTING ON IT
TODAY BUT THAT MIGHT BE AN
INDICATION THAT YOU WANT TO TALK
TO HIM BEFORE COMES TO THE FLOOR
I APPRECIATE WITHOUT WHICH LIKE
CLOTHES I WAS REQUEST WE ARE
VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT OF THE
ROLL CALL THANK YOU SENATOR
RADICALLY.
MOVING BACK TO THE SENATE
JACKSON [inaudible]
SENATOR JACKSON'S.
GOOD MORNING I'M SHOCKED TO SEE
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING ON SUSPENSE BILLS.
I SAID A GENTLE HINT.
IT IS WE HAVE JORDAN FORTY FOUR
BILLS TODAY SO I'M HOPING WE CAN
MOVE THROUGH SOME OF THESE PAST
WE HAVE A COUPLE AND I THINK
FOLKS WHO ARE HERE FOR SOME
OTHER BILLS SO WE'RE GOING MOVE.
THROUGH THESE FAST YOU'RE
WELCOME TO PRESENT WILL START
WITH.
S. B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX WELL IT
IF IT'S ANY CONSOLATION I THINK
I HAD EIGHT OR NINE AND I
REDUCED IT DOWN TO THREE BUT WE
WILL BE BRIEF.
WE WILL BE BRIEF.
MY WITNESSES WILL BE BRIEF.
ALRIGHT S. B. EIGHT TWENTY SIX
IS A BILL THAT DEALS WITH HAVING --
WOMEN ON CORPORATE BOARDS THIS
IS A PROACTIVE APPROACH TO
REQUIRE MORE WOMEN DIRECTORS ON
BOARDS A PUBLICLY HELD
CORPORATIONS.
THAT ARE BASED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA --
WE ARE AT 15% ALTHOUGH WE ARE
52% OF POPULATION WE ARE 70% OF
THE CONSUMERS.
WE TRIED TO DO A MEASURE IS A
RESOLUTION GENTLY PRODDING
COMPANIES TO REEVALUATE THEIR
POSITIONS ON THIS WE GOT NO
WHERE THIS IS A BILL THAT IT
WILL REQUIRE IT.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
INTRODUCE MY ONE WITNESS WHO
WILL BE BRIEF ON SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE.
I REMIND SENATOR I BELIEVE I'M A
CO AUTHOR ON THIS BILL SO YES
INDEED.
QUICKLY WOULD BE NINE THAT'S A
BURKE A MARK FOR THEIR AYE AND
THE OF BOARD MEMBER OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF WOMEN
BUSINESS OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA
WHO.
BROUGHT FORWARD THE BILL WE ARE
ALL FULL OF BOARD MEMBERS AND AS
THE SENATOR SAID ONLY ONE ONE
FOURTH.
OF THE COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA
DO NOT HAVE ANY WOMEN ON THEIR
BOARDS PUBLIC COMPANIES AND
THEY'RE VERY PRIVATELY --
DO CONFIDENTIALLY SELECTED THE
BOARD MEMBERS SO IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WOMEN ARE.
CONSIDERED THE PIPELINE IS
OVERFLOWING WITH WOMEN AND ONE
OF THOSE IS RIGHT HERE AMY
BERNARD BY.
THANK YOU AS EXPERIENCED TO
CORPORATE BOARDS ATTORNEY
LICENSED BY THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR AND A PREVIOUS CORPORATE
HUMAN RESOURCES OFFICER.
CORPORATE BOARD SEARCHES ARE
HANDLED VERY CONFIDENTIAL AND
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS --
INDEPENDENT RESEARCH STUDIES
HAVE PROVEN THAT WOMEN ONBOARD
SPRING TAX REVENUES AND MORE
PROFITABLE COMPANIES.
MACKENZIE AND CREDIT SUISSE HAVE
ISSUED REPORTS.
AND THERE'LL BE NO COST TO THE
STATE FOR RESEARCH FOR THE SPELL
SORRY PRESHOW YOUR SUPPORT PRESS
BEEF TO SIX THANK YOU.
THANK YOU EITHER SPEAKERS ENOUGH
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
YESES AND STAINS I AM OF A WOMAN
BUSINESS OWNER AND I REPRESENT
NOVEL CALIFORNIA AS A BOARD
MEMBER AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
HI AND LET ME WHY IT WITH THAT
LIBBY Y. IT PR BUSINESS OWNER
AND A BOARD MEMBER OF NOVEL
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SCENE NINE SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
EVERY.
I SEE NONE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE SECRETARY OF STATE ESTIMATES
SIGNIFICANT BUT UNKNOWN GENERAL
FUND AND BUSINESS PEOPLE AND
COSTS PRESIDENT INVESTIGATIONS
COMPILING REPORTS AND IT IN
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS.
WE KNOW THAT THE STATE WOULD
LIKELY INCUR SIGNIFICANT COSTS
TO THE LITIGATION ON A VARIETY
OF FRONTS AS A RESULT OF THIS
MEASURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS SEEN NONE --
CENTER JACKSON YOU LIKED CLOSE
IS VERY BRIEFLY OF THAT THE TIME
HAS COME FOR THIS THIS IS A
BENEFIT ALL THE COMPANIES A
EUROPE REQUIRES THIS THEY
DEMONSTRATED THAT WHEN YOU HAVE
WOMEN IN SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS ON
BOARDS.
THE COMPANIES ARE MORE
PRODUCTIVE AND MORE PROFITABLE
AND WITH THAT I WOULD ASK HERE.
AYE VOTE CONSIDERATION IN THIS A
BILL IS ON THE SUSPENSE FILE
THINK YOU THAT WILL BE MADE IN
SUSPENSE ABOUT.
WHICH YOU WILL.
LIKE TO MAKE A PRESENTATION ON
S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR WHICH IS
ALSO A SUSPENSE CANDIDATE VERY
BRIEFLY --
THIS MEASURE WILL PROHIBIT THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION FROM
APPROVING LEASES THAT ALLOW FOR
THE DEVELOPMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR NEW OR
ADDITIONAL OIL AND GAS PRODUCED
FROM FEDERAL WATERS.
THE CONCERN IS THAT THERE ARE
KNOWN COSTS OF THE FUNDING THAT
WE WILL LOSE BECAUSE OF THIS --
I WOULD LIKE TO SUBMIT THAT THE
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH OIL SPILLS --
ON THE ECONOMY AND A NATURAL
RESOURCES IS FAR GREATER THAN
ANY LOSS THAT WE COULD
PROSPECTIVELY POSSIBLY MAYBE
ANTICIPATED AND WITH THAT --
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
DURING ITS PERIOD ON SUSPENSE
THANK YOU EITHER SUPPORTERS.
RICHARD CHARTER ON BEHALF OF THE
OCEAN FOUNDATION SUPPORT.
BEFORE WE GET TO THAT I THINK
THERE'S A FEW AT THE TABLE SO ON
HAND RIGHT THERE [inaudible]
THAT'S RIGHT.
BARRY OKAY MADAM CHAIR VERY
BROAD ON BEHALF OF UNITE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THREE
SEPARATE IMAGE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL AND THE QUINCY IS
LOBBYING COALITION AND SUPPORT
THINK.
I HAD ANOTHER ON REPRESENTING
NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT COME ON HUSTLE. TO HEAR
TRACTOR MEMBERS WITH SUCH AS
WITH THE WESTERN SYNCHROTRON
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE MEASURE.
THE BODY HERE APPROVED A SIMILAR
MEASURE NOT ENTIRELY THE SAME AB
SEVENTEEN SONNY FIVE THE ONLY
DIFFERENCE IS THAT THIS BILL AN
ARMY WOULD APPLY TO EXISTING
LEASES AS WELL.
NOW WE ARE CONCERNS NOW WITH ALL
OF THE FISCAL --
IMPACTS NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS SO
WE REMAIN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR P. ANTHONY
THOMAS RIBS IN THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION SEPAHAN --
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT BRIEFLY SOME
KEY TERMS IN POINTS IN THE
ANALYSIS GENERAL FUND REVENUES
LOSSES IN THE MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS INCREASE ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS.
IN THE SEVERAL HUNDRED MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS POTENTIAL JOURNAL
PHONE CALL TO SOMEBODY
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASED RISK
OF LITIGATION.
AND THESE COSTS AND NOT BEFORE
GONE THIS ANCILLARY COSTS.
STATUS FACING --
UNKNOWN COSTS DUE TO MANY THINGS
[inaudible]
EXCLUDING ARE THE FIRE
DEVASTATION FROM CARMINA SEE
KNOWS WHAT IS READING.
AND IN THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE
EXCEEDING THE ESTIMATED CURRENT
COST OF SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
THE LACK OF CONSIDERATION OF THE
BILL ON THE STATE'S REVENUES
WHETHER FIRES WERE HERE NOT MUST
BE TAKEN INTO CONSIDERATION --
FOR HIS BILL TO STAY ON SUSPENSE.
GIVEN THAT BACKDROP ON EACH TIME
AT THIS BILL COMES UP OUR
QUESTION IS THE SAME.
WHAT IS THE GOAL OF THE BILL
WHAT IS DEBILITATED TO
ACCOMPLISH IN EACH TIME THE
ACTIONS?
ARE IN PRODUCTION AT ALL COSTS.
COSTA WHOSE BENEFIT COSTA WHOSE
DEMISE.
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN FACED WITH
THAT SCENARIO INDUSTRY HAS NO
CHOICE BUT TO PRESENT IN ALL
OPPOSITION TO PROPOSAL SUCH OF
SB. THIRTY FOUR THE BILL
APPLYING TO EXISTING LEASES A
NON STARTER FOR SIP OF AND THE
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO WORK IN HE ALL THE
GAS INDUSTRY.
I'M HERE IN THE CALIFORNIA.
I MAY REMIND THE MEMBERS HERE
THAT THAT'S THE SAME AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
MEMBERS ACOSTA TOO SEVERE FOR
THIS BILL TO ADVANCE AND WE
WOULD RECOMMEND THAT REMAIN ON
SUSPENSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION
ADAM RIGHTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CAL CHAMBER ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU --
CURRENT FINANCE.
THIS BILL COULD RESULT IN
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A DECREASE
GENERAL FUND REVENUE BECAUSE OF
LOS COMPENSATION FROM RIGHT AWAY
LEASE REVENUE.
AND EARLY TERMINATION OF
EXISTING OIL.
AND NATURAL GAS LEASES
COMMISSION INDICATES THIS BILL --
WILL RESULT IN UNKNOWN BUT
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD LIKELY IN
THE SEVERAL HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY --
ADDITIONALLY THE COMMISSION
INDICATES THAT WOULD EXPECT AN
INCREASED RISK OF LITIGATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE SENATE
JACKSON YES THANK YOU --
I JUST LIKE FOR YOU CLOSE I'M
SORRY --
CALDERON WOULD I KNOW THAT
THERE'S A COMPANION MEASURE OR
POTENTIAL COMPANION MEASURE THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON RESEARCHERS
WORKING ON I'M LINES I JUST
THINK I WANT TO MAKE IT VERY
CLEAR.
THAT WE ARE NOT OKAY EXISTE WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TELLING
US THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE ANY
MORE OIL.
PLATFORMS BEING PUT UP OFF OF
OUR COAST.
I DON'T CARE IF IT'S GOING TO BE
IN FEDERAL WATERS YOU'RE NOT
BRINGING IT DOWN.
YEAH ONTO OUR LAND WE ARE NOT
OKAY WHAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT'S GONNA DO YOU AND
WE'RE GONNA DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
TO MAKE SURE WE PUSHED BACK AS A
STATE AGAINST THAT TYPE OF
NONSENSE.
HE TOOK MY CLOSING REMARKS AWAY
THAT WOULD BE GREAT I THINK --
MISTER CALDERON IS COMMENTS IS A
CLOSE IN MY AYE WILL ADOPT THOSE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CLOSING THE
DOOR THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IRRESPECTIVE OF OTHER.
LEGISLATION THIS ONE CLOSES A
DOOR AT NO OPENING FOR NEW
OFFSHORE FEDERAL LEASES OR
EXPANDING THAT UP BEYOND WHAT
THE LAW CURRENTLY ALLOWS WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT IN CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU THAT DOESN'T DISPENSED.
DO YOU HAVE --
I THINK ONE OTHER BILLION ONE
PRESENT ON S. B. TWELVE SIXTY
THAT AWESOME IS BEING MOVED T
SUSPECTS VERY BRIEFLY THIS IS
THE BILL THAT STARTS ADDRESSING
OR WILDFIRE SITUATION HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS A BILL IT'S AN OMNIBUS
FIRE PREVENTION OF FORESTRY
MANAGEMENT BILL THAT WILL
PROMOTE LONG TERM FOREST HEALTH
AND WILDFIRE RESILIENCY
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
AS OUR OF THE COMMITTEE.
HAS INDICATED FOR FROM THE TO
THERE ARE NO PLANS THERE ARE NO
OVERALL PLANTS TO TRY TO REDUCE --
FIRE A LIKELIHOOD TO PREVENT IT
AND TO ADDRESS THOSE FIRES AS
THEY OCCUR THIS IS THE BILL THAT
DOES THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS PUT
MONEY.
I IN THE BUDGET FOR THIS IS A
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT BILL WE
NEED TO START WE NEED TO START
YESTERDAY IF WE CAN'T START
YESTERDAY WITH THE START WITH
THIS BILL AND WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURES COMES FORWARD.
THANK YOU OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
A MEAN OR TIAS ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT THINKING.
DE AND YORK ON BEHALF OF THE
WHILE LANCE CONSERVANCY IN SPORT.
WE GOING THAT LINUS I WITH THAT
SANDIEGO GAS ELECTRIC COMPANY
IN SUPPORT AND HAPPY TO WORK
WITH AUTHOR AND TO IMPROVE AYE
NOTIFICATIONS THAT UTILITIES AND
UP PLANNING PROCESS CAN WORK
TOGETHER.
THANK YOU.
JUST AN OLD FEEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JASON BROUGHT UP WE HAVE WESTERN
AYE DURING THE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEN NOT DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE TOTAL COST FOR CALIFORNIA OR
IN THE AIR BE TO IMPLEMENT THIS
BILL APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT
FIVE MILLION IN. TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIVE POINT ONE MILLION
IN NINETEEN TWENTY AND FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION ONGOING.
FINANCE ESTIMATES BILL WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
COSTS TO SUPPORT LOCAL HERE.
DISTRICT PARTICIPATION IN
IMPLEMENTATION AS REQUIRED BY
THE BILL AND TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO SAVE ENTITIES
INCLUDING HELLFIRE TYPICALLY
MORE PRESCRIBED FIRE PROJECTS.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE SENATOR JEFF VERY BRIEF
WITH THE COST OF THE FIRES THAT
ARE DEVASTATING THIS STATE THAT
IS CHUMP CHANGE.
AND IT IS MONEY THAT IS WELL
SPENT ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
HEALTH THE SAFETY AND THE
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF THE
PEOPLE THE STATE I WOULD URGE
YOUR CONSIDERATION WHEN IT'S ON
SUSPEND [inaudible]
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND THAT
COMPLETES YOUR PRESENTATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW MOVE.
TO CENTER GALGIANI.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I AM WAITING PRESENTATION ON SP
TWELVE TWENTY THREE SB TWELVE
SEVENTY TWO AN SP.
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX AND I WANTED
TO PRESENT ON S. B. TWELVE FORTY
NINE SP TWELVE FORTY NINE
PROHIBITS THE SALE PROMOTIONAL
GIVEAWAY.
OF ANY COSMETIC PRODUCT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS BEEN TESTED
ON ANIMALS AFTER JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY WITH AT LEAST
FOUR EXEMPTIONS.
FIRST THIS INCLUDES ANY EVENT
THAT THE FDA OR THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCE
CONTROL REQUIRES TESTING.
SECOND IF TESTING IS NEEDED TO
COMPLY WITH THE FORMAL REQUEST
OF A FOREIGN REGULATORY
AUTHORITY UP UNTIL.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THIRD IF
TESTING IS CONDUCTED FOR NON
COSMETIC PURPOSE AND FOURTH IF
TESTING WAS USED IN DEVELOPMENT
OF A PHARMACEUTICAL.
S. B. TWELVE FORTY NINE ALSO
GRANDFATHERS AND THOUSANDS OF
CURRENT COSMETIC PRODUCTS AND
INGREDIENTS THIS MEASURE HAS
LITTLE TO NO FISCAL IMPACT HAS
NOTED IN THE COMMITTEES ANALYSIS
WITH ME TODAY ARE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE BILL'S
SPONSOR TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JUDY MAN
WHO CELL AND I AM THE PRESIDENT
AND FOUNDER OF SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION WE ARE CO
SPONSORED THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA HAS HAD A LONG
HISTORY OVER EIGHTEEN YEARS OF
PROHIBITING IN STATE ANIMAL
TESTING FOR COSMETIC PRODUCTS.
S. B. TWELVE FORTY NINE SIMPLY
BRINGS CALIFORNIA'S HUMANE
STANDARDS IN LINE WITH AT LEAST
THIRTY FIVE OTHER COUNTRIES.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS MEASURE
WILL HAVE A LITTLE FISCAL IMPACT
IF ANY ON CALIFORNIA.
JOHN PAUL MITCHELL SYSTEMS A
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANY WITH
SALES OF OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
HAS BEEN CRUELTY FREE SINCE
THEIR INCEPTION OVER THIRTY
EIGHT YEARS AGO.
I ALSO MIGHT MENTION THAT THEY
SELL THEIR PRODUCTS IN CHINA.
AND NEGOTIATED WITH THE CHINESE
REGULATORS TO CONTINUE TO BE
CRUELTY FREE BY USING
ALTERNATIVE TESTING.
AND THAT THAT TEST CAME FROM THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA WE WILL
JOIN THE EUROPEAN UNION AND
DOZENS OF OTHER COUNTRIES AND
SUPPORTING THE OVER THREE
THOUSAND COMPANIES GLOBALLY.
FROM SMALL INDEPENDENT BUSINESS
TO GLOBAL LEADERS THAT HAVE
ALREADY GONE CRUELTY FREE.
THANK YOU.
IT IS OUR SMALL SPORT.
HOW MANY OF US CHRISTIE SORUM
I'M A TOXICOLOGIST WITH THE
PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE?
THE GOOD TIMES TO BE A
TOXICOLOGIST SINCE VERY EXCITING
SCIENCE OUT THERE.
IN FUTURE TESTING AS A MULTI
BILLION DOLLAR MARKET AND ONE OF
THE FASTEST GROWING AREAS OF
SCIENCE THAT CALIFORNIA AND IN
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY STANDS
TO BENEFIT FROM.
WE'VE SEEN LEGISLATION ONE OF
THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY A DOCTOR
EGGMAN.
AND A SECOND BY MISS KOREA YOU
CAN CONTINUE ON STREET.
WE'VE SEEN THIS LEGISLATION WHAT
IN THE EVEN OTHER COUNTRIES
GALVANIZE AND INSPIRE INVESTMENT.
IN NEW TECHNOLOGY TO ENSURE
ENSURE SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS
AND WE EXPECT THE SAME WILL
RESULT FROM THIS BILL.
HOWEVER THESE THINGS DON'T
CHANGE ON THEIR OWN WE NEED TO
SPELL TO GIVE CONSUMERS WHAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR WHICH IS SAFE
AND CRUELTY FREE COSMETICS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS NICHOLAS SOCKET
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
FOR SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION I'M JUST HERE TO
HELP ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY.
THANK YOU AT THIS POINT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE SUPPORTERS THAT ARE
GOING TO STATE THEIR NAME OTHER
ORGANIZATION AND THE POSITION.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS ASHLEY
WELL THEN WITH THE HUMANE
SOCIETY OF THE UNITED STATES AND
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
SPELL.
DEFTLY IF YOU KEEP GOING DENISE
BUBBLE SAN MATEO COUNTY IN
SUPPORT PLEASE LISTEN TO THE
PEOPLE.
I REPEAT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE AND NAME IF YOU'RE WITH AN
ORGANIZATION AND SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE.
THANK YOU AND WE'RE GONNA GO
QUICKLY LET'S GO REMAKE MAINS
EDUCATOR MEMBER OF PITA IN
SUPPORT.
RABBI JONATHAN KLEIN.
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF FAITH
ACTION FOR ANIMALS YES.
CRYSTAL MINOR FROM NEW LIFE
ANIMAL SANCTUARY AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
JACKIE DAY AUTHOR AND TEACHER OF
THE YEAR SUPPORT.
ELIZABETH BAKER PHYSICIANS
COMMITTEE FOR RESPONSIBLE
MEDICINE IN SUPPORT.
DEBOAH CLAUSSEN NEVADA
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF MY EX
LAB BUNNY MARI IN SUPPORT.
MARGARET SULLIVAN IN SUPPORT.
WE YOU STURGIS SOCIAL
COMPASSIONATE LEGISLATION FROM
LOS ANGELES AND SUPPORT.
MONICA ENGELBREKTSSON FROM
CRUELTY FREE INTERNATIONAL IN
SUPPORT.
LISA WHERE YOU SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT IN SUPPORT.
HI JENNIFER KENNEDY FROM EL
DORADO COUNTY CALIFORNIA AND
VERY STRONG SUPPORT REPRESENTING
A TEST U. S. THANK YOU.
CHRISTY RALLY IN SUPPORT.
SOME ANDREAS SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION FROM LOS ANGELES IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI ERICA NIELSEN FROM LOS
ANGELES PHYSICIANS COMMITTEE FOR
RESPONSIBLE MEDICINE IN SUPPORT.
DR KELLY BIGELOW DERMATOLOGIST
IN MOST SURGEON IN LOS ANGELES
IN SUPPORT.
INDEED BAKER AND LILY STRANDED
SUPPORT.
HEATHER JORDAN IN SUPPORT.
HE'S FAR IN SUPPORT.
KIMBERLY LA IN SUPPORT.
EDU VIELE CEMETERY COUNTY
REPRESENTING HUMANITY THROUGH
EDUCATION AND SUPPORT.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL FOR MARINA
DEL REY CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
PRESIDENT OF WORLD THEM ON USING
PIECE RAMBLES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS WITH THAT --
EFFORT TO MAKE SOME ROOM FOR THE
OPPOSITION TO COME UP.
TO EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
WE NEED TO SPOTS AT THE DESK.
MADAM CHAIR MADE NEARLY ON
BEHALF OF THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION THAT REPRESENTS THE
PERSONAL CARE AND COSMETICS
INDUSTRY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTING ABOUT A HUNDRED
COMPANIES ARE BASED.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA I'M PROUD TO
CALL CALIFORNIA HOME.
AND WE HAVE THE SIGNIFICANT
POLICY CONCERNS ABOUT RESPECT
FOR YOUR TIME AND COMMITTEES
TIME WE WILL LEAVE THOSE --
OFF THE TABLE FOR NOW UNLESS WE
GET QUESTIONS BUT ON THE FISCAL --
TO THE EXTENT THAT THIS BILL AND
WE DO BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL
RESULT IN PRODUCT RECALLS AND
PRODUCT BANDS.
THERE WILL BE A SALES TAX HIT ON
THE STATE AS WELL AS THE FACT
THAT WE BELIEVE AND GIVEN WHAT
THAT PROPONENTS HAVE PROPOSED TO
US.
ABOUT THE SOLUTION AROUND AND
THE SUNSET PROVISION ON THE
FOREIGN GOVERNMENT REQUIREMENT.
SUGGESTING TO US THAT WE SHOULD
MOVE JOBS CALIFORNIA JOBS OUT TO
CHINA.
AND TO THE EXTENT THAT THAT
OCCURRED AS WE BELIEVE THERE
WILL BE A STATE IMPACT ON A
STATE INCOME TAXES TO THE STATE --
SO THOSE ARE THE FISCAL CONCERNS
THAT WE HAVE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS OF THE POLICY IF
THERE ARE ANY WITH COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS VERY PROUD
TO BE HAVE TO THE TEAMSTERS WE
REPRESENT.
EMPLOYEES IN MANUFACTURING
TRANSPORTATION LOGISTICS IN THIS
INDUSTRY [inaudible]
OF THE THAT THE FISCAL.
I THINK THE FISCAL ISSUES I
THINK I'VE BEEN SPOKEN TO BY
NESTLE ON OUR CONCERNS ARE
LARGELY POLICY MATTERS I DO
BELIEVE THAT ACTUALLY THE
PROPONENTS.
AND THE OPPONENTS ARE NOT REALLY
WE AGREE THAT WE SHOULD JOIN THE
EUROPEAN UNION AND A MODEL THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE EUROPEAN
UNION.
WHO WOULD THE ISSUES COME UP IS
WE DON'T WANT A THE U. S.
EMPLOYERS TO BE PUT IN A
POSITION?
OF HAVING TO CHOOSE BETWEEN
PRODUCTION.
MANUFACTURING OF HIGHLY
DESIRABLE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
EXPORTED [inaudible]
ON BY PRODUCING THOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES OR PRODUCING THOSE
IN CHINA WE'VE HAD ENOUGH JOBS
OFFSHORE. TO CHINA SECONDLY --
TO THE EXTENT THE BILL CONTINUES
TO ALLOW A PRODUCT.
WHICH OF EVEN THOUGH THE COMPANY
NOR NOT OF ITS SUPPLIERS ANIMAL
TEST.
IT THE BILL ALLOWS ANY THIRD
PARTY IN THE WORLD WHO TESTS ANY
COMPONENT PRODUCT.
THAT WOULD SUDDENLY MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA PRODUCT SUBJECT TO
RECALL URINE WOULD NO ACTION ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY AND OUT OF
THE COMPANIES CONTROL.
A WE THINK THAT SHOULD BE FIXED
IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS BUT IF THAT
THAT IS WHAT WOULD LIKELY LEAD
TO THE FISCAL IMPACT OF PRODUCTS
BEING WITHDRAWN FROM CALIFORNIA
NOT BEING SOLD HAVING TO BE
DESTROYED AND AND SO FORTH IN
THAT COULD EFFECT THE JOBS OF
ARMY.
SO WE ABOUT OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED POSITION THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION.
MAUREEN HAGENS REPRESENTING
VIACOM ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
JOHN KEPT YET HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATIONS ALSO IN
A POSITION.
NICKEL COMMUTERS ON BEHALF OF
THE FRAGRANCE CREATORS
ASSOCIATION OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSED.
TERRY THOMAS ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSUMER HEALTHCARE PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION THE TRADE
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING THE
MANUFACTURES OVER THE COUNTER
DRUG PRODUCTS IN OPPOSITION.
CAITLYN COLEMAN CIVIL JUSTICE
ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION.
ADAMANTLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
AARON ROBERT ON BEHALF OF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS
ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION.
MISS AT SHOREHAM TO HAVE THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
IN OPPOSITION.
LEE ABOUT US ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
KATHY PROCEED ON BEHALF OF
JOHNSON JOHNSON IN OUR FAMILY OF
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA YOUR
OPPOSE UNLESS IT IS AMENDED.
HI BETH PERSONS WITH PROCTER AND
GAMBLE OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED.
SEE NOW THEIR OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE KNOW THAT THIS BILL HAS THE
POTENTIAL TO ADD TO THE COURTS
CASELOAD.
HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE
COURTS WANTED WE RECEIVE FUNDING
ON A CASELOAD BASIS THEREFORE
UNLESS THIS PARTICULAR CASE WILL
BECOME SIGNIFICANT IN CAN BE
DOCUMENT AND IT'S LIKELY TO BE
THE SORT.
THANK YOU AYE I DO WANT TO KNOW --
THERE WAS SOME DEBATE ABOUT
WHETHER THIS BILL.
IT WAS KEEP FISCAL AT SOME POINT
WAS NOT KEEP FISCAL --
IN WE DID TAKE THAT
CONSIDERATION AND IT IN
REQUESTING A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I WILL BE VOTING
YES TODAY.
I'M I'M I KNOW THE NUMBER OF OUR
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS WERE GONNA --
ALLOW THEM TO ASK QUESTIONS BUT
I HAVE SOME IS WEALTHY AND MISS
CRAMP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR UP SENATOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL TO THE ATTENTION OF
THIS BODY AS A PET OWNER AS A
CONSUMER OF COSMETICS --
IT HURTS MY HEART TO SEE
PHOTOGRAPHS OF ANIMALS BEAN --
TESTED FOR PRODUCTS THAT WE USE --
I DO WANT TO UNDERSTAND A BIT
MORE THE FISCAL IMPACT ON JOBS
IN MANUFACTURING FOR OUR STATE I
JUST CAME BACK FROM A DELEGATION
TRIP TO CHINA.
AND COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT COUNTRY HAS INCREDIBLY LOW
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS AS WELL
AS STANDARDS FOR THE LABOR
MARKET AND SO I'M HOPING THAT
YOU'VE BEEN ABLE TO TALK TO THE
OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF HOW WE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT AND HOW --
WHERE ABLE TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
GIVEN THE INCREDIBLE OPPOSITION
AND THE IMPACT OF JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA SPECIFICALLY I WILL
BE VOTING?
YES ON THIS BILL TODAY BUT I
HOPE THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME SORT
OF RESOLUTION MOVING FORWARD AND%
THAT LIKE TO UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OF THAT MORE.
WE HAVE ALLOWED ON FOREIGN
EXEMPTION FOR FOREIGN COUNTRY
UNTIL THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
THREE I KNOW THEY'RE STILL
CONCERN OVER THAT DATE.
ON THAT WE WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
DOCTOR QUIRK.
YES WELL I SEE A BIG FISCAL
IMPACT AS WRITTEN DOWN SO BE
VOTING NOW.
IF YOU GO TO THE E. U. MARVEL.
WHERE YOU DON'T PENALIZE
COMPANIES FOR TESTING THAT
OCCURRED OVERSEAS?
I BELIEVE I CAN TO SUPPORT THIS
BUT AGAIN PLEASE GO TO THE U.
MODEL I'LL BE VOTING NO TODAY ON
FISCAL CRAMPS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MISS FRIEDMAN.
THERE'S ANYONE GOING TO BE
AGAINST THE GOALS OF THIS BILL
AND I'M GONNA VOTE TODAY I'M
GONNA VOTE YESTERDAY AS WELL.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO GIVE YOU
SOME OF MY CONCERNS I HOPE THAT
YOU CAN WORK SOME OF THESE
ISSUES OUT SOME OF THEM ARE JUST
QUESTIONS AND SOME I THINK OUR
WORDING ISSUES.
I'M ONE OF MY CONCERNS IS --
WHAT HAPPENS TO AN INGREDIENT IF
ANOTHER COMPANY OR ANOTHER
ENTITY TESTS IT SOMEWHERE IN THE
WORLD WITHOUT?
THAT PARTICULAR MANUFACTURERS
KNOWLEDGE OR WITHOUT THEIR
PARTICIPATION DOES THAT MEAN
THAT THAT INGREDIENT THEN
BECOMES BAND IN THE STATE EVEN
THOUGH [inaudible]
IF COSMETIC COMPANY A DOZEN
TESTS ON ANIMALS NEVER DID AND
THAN COSMETIC COMPANIES SEE IN
SOME OTHER COUNTRY TEST THE SAME
AGREE ON ANIMALS AS I MEAN.
THAT THAT IS.
ABANDONED IT IN OUR IN
CALIFORNIA SO THAT'S A QUESTION
THAT'S NOT IN THE BILL SO.
I'D YOU KNOW WHETHER OR NOT YOU
INTEND THAT IS A WHOLE DIFFERENT
STORY BUT I'D LIKE TO HAVE THAT
DEALT WITH SOMEWHERE IN THE TEXT
OF THE BILL SO THAT THERE'S
CLARITY.
SO THAT'S NUMBER.
ONE IT'S TESTED OUTSIDE OF THE
PARTICULAR MANUFACTURERS --
PURVIEW SECONDLY IN TERMS OF THE
FAR EXEMPTION I COULD BE WRONG
BUT WHAT I'VE BEEN TOLD IS THAT
THE WAY THAT IT WORKS IS THAT IF
YOU.
AND WITH CHINA IS THAT A PRODUCT
IS MANUFACTURED INSIDE OF CHINA
I GUESS BECAUSE OF THEIR
EXTREMELY HIGH ENVIRONMENTAL
STANDARDS HE DOESN'T HAVE TO BE
TESTED ON ANIMALS BUT IF IT'S
POSTED OUTSIDE OF CHINA IT DOES
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT FOR
MANUFACTURERS.
THEIR ONLY CHOICE IS GOING TO BE
TO MAKE DE THEIR NOT SO TO CHINA
OR MANUFACTURE INSIDE OF CHINA.
AND I THINK THAT'S YOU KNOW
THAT'S A REAL ISSUE --
SO IF YOUR INTENTION IS AND I'M
I LET YOU ANSWER THIS ONE IS
YOUR ATTENTION IS THAT IT'S FINE
IF ALL THE MAIN.
CHINA BECAUSE THEN THERE'S NO
ANIMAL TESTING.
THAT IS NOT THE INTENTION OF THE
BILL THAT'S ABSOLUTELY NOT THE
INTENTION AND AYE THE THERE ARE
CONVERSATION STILL OCCURRING
ABOUT WHAT THAT TIMELINE IS WITH
THE TIMELINE DOESN'T MATTER AND
HEALTH WHERE YOU'RE BASICALLY
SAYING WITH THAT BY FOR YEARS
THEY HAVE.
TO CHINA IF THEY'RE GONNA SELL
TO CHINA BECAUSE A HALF THE
PRODUCTS HAVE TO BE TESTED ON
ANIMALS TO BE IMPORTED INTO
CHINA.
SO THE TIME I JUST MEANS THAT
THEY HAVE ANOTHER COUPLE YEARS
THEY CAN OPERATE HERE AND SO
IMPORTANT CHINA AFTER THAT THEY
HAVE TO MOVE OR NOT SELL YES I'M
GONNA ALLOW MY SPONSOR TO TO
RESPOND TO THAT BUT FIRST LET ME
RESPOND TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION.
WHICH WAS WITH REGARD TO ANOTHER
COMPANY TAKING ANOTHER
INGREDIENT I AND TESTING IT ON
ANIMALS AND THAT FIRST COMPANY
DOESN'T KNOW THAT THAT'S
OCCURRED.
WE DID TAKE AMENDMENTS THAT THAT
SAY THAT THE COMPANY IS NOT
LIABLE IF WAS TESTED BY SOME
OTHER COMPANY.
IF THAT NEEDS TO BE TIGHTENED UP
WE CAN LOOK AT THAT YEAH THAT'S
NO BIG SO EVEN IF THEY KNOW
THOUGH WHETHER THEY KNOW OR NOT
IS NOT YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT
RELEVANT IF ANOTHER IF THEY HAVE
THAT AS AN INGREDIENT AND THEY
KNOW THAT SOMEONE ELSE TESTS IT.
THEN THEY STILL CAN'T USE IT
EVEN IF IT'S TESTED AFTER THE
MAIN THEY INTRODUCED IT
ACCORDING TO YOUR BILL SO I'M
JUST SAYING I THINK THAT
SOMETHING SO FIVE BY HAVE MY
PRODUCT AND I'VE INTRODUCED IT.
AND THEN WHATEVER OF SOMETIMES
SOME OTHER COMPANY TESTED ON
ANIMALS THAT MEANS I HAVE TO
PULL IT OFF THE SHELF RIGHT EVEN
THOUGH I DIDN'T HAVE TROLL OVER
THAT.
NO IT IS NOT WE TOOK AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THAT SPECIFICALLY AND
IT'S NOT DETAILED IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS ANALYSIS BUT WE
DID.
TAKE AMENDMENTS TO THAT EFFECT
SORT LOT AND I'LL WELL THAT WE
HAVE IN PRINT IT'S A DIFFERENCE
NOT IT'S NOT REFLECT IS NOT IN
THE ANALYSIS WELFARE SO I REALLY
BILLS IN THE BILL KNOW THE BILL
SAYS KNOWINGLY.
SO KNOWINGLY OR NOT IS NOT THE
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY CONCERN YOU
MIGHT KNOW BUT YOU HAD NO
CONTROL OVER GREAT.
SO I I'M GONNA I'M GONNA TAKE OF
THE CHINA PIECE AND THEN I'M
GONNA LET OUR TOXICOLOGIST GO TO
THOSE SECOND --
ONE SO.
FIRST OF ALL WE ARE NOT PRO
MOVING JOBS TO CHINA OKAY SO
LET'S JUST.
GET THAT OUT --
WHAT WE WERE TOLD IF IT IN THE
BEGINNING OF DOING THIS BILL BY
THE OPPOSITION WAS ABSOLUTELY
POSITIVELY?
NO ONE CAN SELL THEIR PRODUCTS
IN CHINA.
WITHOUT TESTING ON ON PAIN THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO TEST THEIR
PRODUCT IN LESS.
YOU HAD A MANUFACTURING PLANT IN
CHINA [inaudible]
OKAY.
THEN TO DO OUR DUE DILIGENCE ON
THE BILL.
WE SPOKE TOO MANY MANUFACTURERS
THAT ARE CRUELTY FREE AND THE
ONE IN PARTICULAR IS JOHN PAUL
MITCHELL SYSTEMS.
THEY HAVE BEEN IN SANTA CLARITA
FOR THIRTY EIGHT YEARS THEY MAKE
OVER A BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
AND THEY'VE BEEN CRUELTY FREE
SINCE INCEPTION.
THEY WENT TO CHINA THEY WANNA BE
AND THE CHINA AND THE CHINESE
MARKET.
AND THE CHINESE REGULATORS SAY.
WE HAVE TO TOUCH OUR PRODUCTS ON
ANIMALS AND THEY SAID
[inaudible]
NO.
WORK CRUELTY FREE AND WE WANT TO
CONTINUE TO BE CRUELTY FREE.
SO THEY WORKED WITH THE
REGULATORS A FINE ATTEST.
THAT WAS AMICABLE TO BOTH SIDES
IT'S A SKIN TEST OUT OF BOSTON A
COMPANY CALLED MATT TACK.
UP AND THEY USE THAT. TO START
PUTTING THEIR SKEWS THROUGH AND
TESTING.
SO THERE'S A COUPLE DIFFERENT
MODELS OF HOW YOU CAN BE IN
CHINA TODAY FORGET ABOUT THIS
BILL COMPLETELY.
AND TEN DAYS BE IN CHINA WITHOUT
TESTING ON ANIMALS THE OTHER WAY
IS TO SET UP A STORE FRONT IN
SHANGHAI.
AND YOU'RE ALLOWED TO TO THEN.
PUT YOUR PRODUCTS INTO THE
CHINESE MARKET FROM THERE.
A THIRD WAY WHICH IS I BELIEVE
IT WAS A MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR
INDUSTRY AND I CAN SEND YOU THE
LINKS FOR THESE ARTICLES --
IS THROUGH ALI BABA WHICH IS THE
LARGEST ONLINE RETAILER IN THE
WORLD.
SO THERE IS NO REASON TO NOT BE
IN CHINA.
NUMBER ONE YOU CAN BE IN CHINA
AND YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE CRUEL
TO BE THERE.
THE CHINESE ALL LET.
CHRISTY SPEAK TO THOSE THAT ARE
ALREADY PHASING OUT CERTAIN
TESTS THAT WERE REQUIRED THAT.
WERE ANIMAL TEST [inaudible]
SO THAT'S SPEAKS TO THAT AND AS
FAR AS JOBS AND I'M SORRY THAT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK MOVED AWAY.
WE HAVE --
ARTICLES FROM REUTERS BLOOMBERG
C. N. B. C. AND FROM THE
EUROPEAN UNION THAT AFTER THIS
WAS IMPLEMENTED.
IN THE EUROPEAN UNION THAT THE
ALTERNATIVE TESTING MARKET AND
THE SCIENCE MARKETS HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE ROOF AND THEY ARE
THE ONE A THIRTY EIGHT BILLION
DOLLAR INDUSTRY.
SO THERE'S BEEN NEW JOBS AND NEW
SCIENCE SO IT IS A JOB CREATOR
THERE IS NO REASON. TO LOSE JOBS
OVER THIS BILL AND THE ONE
MISCONCEPTION THAT WE KEEP
HEARING FROM EVERYONE THAT THE
OPPOSITION IS DOING A GREAT JOB
IN CONFUSING EVERYONE.
IS THAT ALL OF THE INGREDIENTS
RIGHT NOW TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
INGREDIENTS ARE GRANDFATHERED IN.
SO WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT IS
JUST NEW INGREDIENTS.
AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY IT IS WHAT IS
CREATED THAT IS BRAND NEW THAT'S
NOT TENS OF THOUSANDS THAT MIGHT
NOT EVEN BE HUNDREDS.
AND WE'RE SAYING WE WANT THOSE
NEW INGREDIENTS [inaudible]
TESTED ALTERNATIVELY NOT ON AN
ANIMAL AND THE BEST PART ABOUT
THAT IS THOSE ALTERNATIVES SAY
OF A TEST ARE SAFER FOR HUMANS.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF
MISCONCEPTION HERE AND WE ARE SO
HAPPY TO CLEAR IT UP AND WE'VE
TAKEN AMENDMENTS AND AND PEOPLE
HAVE EVEN COME OFF THE BILL
OPPOSITION HAVE ANY INCOME OFF
THE BILL.
BUT WE THOUGHT HE HAD THAT
SHOULD BE COVERED LET'S PUT IT
IN THERE GUY OKAY WE'RE GONNA
STICK TO THAT.
DURING THE QUESTIONS BECAUSE
IT'S GETTING A LITTLE BIT
FURTHER THAN THE SCOPE I SHAN'T.
SAY LASTLY I'D I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE YOU ON BESIDES THE FTA
EXEMPTION PUT ANOTHER AGENCIES
BECAUSE I'M TOLD THERE ARE WE
ALMOST RAN A BILL ABOUT WATER
QUALITY TESTS ON FISH.
SO WITH SOME OF THE THINGS LIKE
SOME BLOCKS THERE'S THERE ARE
OTHER AGENCIES THAT SOMETIMES
REQUIRE TESTING THANK YOU SO YOU
MIGHT ONCE HAVE BEEN CUT IS HERE
VERY BRIEFLY FROM THE OPPOSITION
ABOUT THE CHINA THING JUST TO
HAVE IT ON RECORD AND THEN.
YEAH AND I HAVE ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS SO WE DO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO HER NOW WOULD YOU.
BUT AFTER IS FINE AND AGAIN I GO
I'M GONNA VOTE YESTERDAY AND YOU
KNOW I I HOPE THAT THESE CAN ALL
BE ANSWERED SO EVERYONE CAN VOTE
YES.
THINK THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION
MISS FRIEDMAN --
ON THAT CHINA PIECE AND THE DEAL
THAT JOHN PAUL MITCHELL CUT WITH
CHINA.
AS COMPANIES AND IS MULTI
NATIONAL GLOBAL COMPANIES WE
RELY ON CERTAINTY AND WE FOLLOW
THE RULES WE COMPLY WITH FORMAL
REQUIREMENTS FROM FROM FOREIGN
ENTITIES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FROM STATE GOVERNMENT
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
SO WE CAN'T RELY ON THIS DEAL
ALSO CALLED DO YOU KNOW THAT A
COMPANY CUT WITH --
THE COUNTRY OF CHINA THAT GIVES
US NO CERTAINTY AT ALL --
ONE THING THAT I DO WANT TO FLAG
THAT ON THIS ME KUSA POINTED OUT
ABOUT JOBS BEING CREATED IN THE
U..
WE ARE SUPPORTING FULL ALIGNMENT
WITH THE EU TO BE VERY CLEAR.
WE WANT TO AND ANIMAL TOUGH OKAY
HAS PASSED BEYOND THE SCOPE OF
THIS QUESTION SO WE WILL.
CONTINUE OUR THEIR ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS.
IF NOT I HAVE A FEW.
I AM SO.
THIS GALGIANI AYE I THINK YOU
FOR BRINGING US FOR IS SOMEBODY
WHO CARES DEEPLY ABOUT ANIMALS --
YOU KNOW ON FIRST BLUSH OF
COURSE IN SUPPORT OF THIS IS
SOMETHING I THINK AND YOU YOU'RE
HEARING IT FROM MY COLLEAGUES
ALL OF US WHO ARE --
EXTREMELY PROGRESSIVE MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY --
EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE IDEA
OF STOPPING TESTING ON ANIMALS
ESPECIALLY THOSE OF US WHO SPEND
A LOT ON COSMETICS --
THERE'S A FEW OF US.
AND PREFER NOT TO HAVE TO LOOK
AT THE LABEL AND SO I'M GRATEFUL.
ON THE OTHER HAND AYE YOU HAVE
SOME THE MOST AGAIN PROGRESSIVE
MEMBERS LEGISLATURE THAT ARE NOW.
ASKING YOU TO REVIEW SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
I AM CONCERNED ABOUT --
THAT THAT ISSUES WITH CHINA.
AND AS WE ARE MOVING FORWARD WE
HAVE TO BE REALISTIC IN A
DIFFERENT AGE I MIGHT OF TOWARD
YOU IT'S OKAY FOR CALIFORNIA
USER MARKETPLACE. TO CHANGE
RULES IN A FOREIGN COUNTRY BUT
THE REALITY IS WE'RE UNDER
PRESIDENCY --
WHO REALLY DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING CALIFORNIA JOBS
AND -- HAS
CREATED SOMEWHAT OF A TRADE WAR
WITH CHINA.
I WOULD HEAT FOR OUR JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA OR THE UNITED STATES --
TO BECOME SUBJECT TO SOME
INTERNATIONAL --
DISPUTES THAT NO WILL BE
RESOLVED BY.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SO IF I'M
FEELING LIKE I'M BEING PLACED IN
A POSITION WHERE I'M BEING ASKED
TO CHOOSE BETWEEN TWO VALUES
THAT I HOLD VERY DEAR.
VERY HERE I MEAN I I HAVE SPENT
MY LIFE TRYING TO PROTECT
AMERICAN JOBS THAT IS WHERE I
COME FROM A MORE WORKER ADVOCATE
I GUARANTEE YOU.
IT IS NOT ACCEPTABLE FOR ME IN
ANY SITUATION TO SAY.
WELL THAT THE JOBS COULD GO WE
COULD DO A STOREFRONT CHINA IT'S
JUST NOT ACCEPTABLE THAT'S NOT
ACCEPTABLE RESPONSE SO I'M
HOPEFUL THAT WE CAN SOMEHOW
ADDRESS.
THIS ASPECT IN VOTING YES TODAY
I ITEM.
CLEARLY IN SUPPORT WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO HERE BUT THAT
CONCERNS ME.
I HAVE A QUICK CONCERN I SEE I
THINK AS WELL WE KEEP HEARING
ABOUT THE EEO AT I GOT A NUMBER
OF TWEETS A SAYS WE JUST WANT
WAY WITH YOUR POWER.
WHAT ARE THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
WHAT THIS LAW SAYS AND WHAT THE
EUROPEAN UNION HAS IN THEIR LAW
AND WHY AM I HEARING TWO
DIFFERENT STORIES ABOUT WHETHER
ADOPTING?
YOU THE EUROPEAN STANDARDS OR
WERE ACTUALLY CREATING A
STANDARD THAT'S HIGHER THAN THAT
IF I COULD GET.
BOTH THE OPPOSITION AND THE
PROPONENTS TO EXPLAIN THAT TO ME
IN THEIR OWN TERMS.
SO WHAT THINK THE EUROPEAN UNION
DEAD.
NOW FIFTEEN YEARS AGO WAS A SET
UP A SYSTEM WHEREBY OVER TIME.
THE CUT OF THEIR EUROPEAN UNION
COSMETICS MARKET WOULD BE.
CREW MORE AND MORE CRUELTY FREE.
AND SO THE FINAL LAW WHICH WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN --
TW THOUSAND THIRTEEN SAID THAT --
ANY INGREDIENTS OR COSMETICS HAD
BEEN TESTED ANYWHERE IN THE
WORLD BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TELEMARKETING.
BAND IN ORDER TO PREVENT TESTERS
FROM JUST GOING TO OTHER
COUNTRIES.
COULD NOT BE SOLD IN THE
EUROPEAN UNION.
NOW THEY CREATED OVER THAT OVER
TIME THE COURTS IN THROUGH
IMPLEMENTATION OF CREATED TO
EXEMPTIONS ONE AS FOR
INTERNATIONAL TESTING WHICH IS
WHAT WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT
WHAT CHINA.
REQUESTING REQUIREMENTS AND ONE
IS FOR THEIR REACH LEGISLATION
WHICH IS A CHEMICAL TESTING
LEGISLATION. FOR INDUSTRIAL
CHEMICALS.
SO THOSE ARE THOSE OF A SANCTION.
ARBIL HOUSE EXEMPTIONS FOR
PRODUCTS TESTED BY THIRD PARTIES.
UP FOR IT UNDER REGULATORY
REQUIREMENT [inaudible]
SO THAT.
IS IT TAKES CARE OF SOME OF THAT
COMES --
WHAT WE FIND WHAT WE HAVE FOUND
OVER THE LAST FIVE YEARS IS THAT
ALMOST ALL ANIMAL TESTING HER
COSMETICS HAS NOW ENDED?
EXCEPT IS FOR THESE REQUIREMENTS
IN --
CERTAIN COUNTRIES AND SO IF WE
WERE TO HAVE A BILL THAT DIDN'T
ADDRESS TESTING THAT HAPPENS IN
CHINA.
IT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN THE FACT.
SO EVEN THAT YOU NOW THE
EUROPEAN GOVERNMENT HAS PASSED A
RESOLUTION JUST A JUST LAST
MONTH.
CALLING FOR A GLOBAL BAN ON
ANIMALS HOUSE COSMETICS SEEMS
THAT THE ORIGINAL YOU LAW FROM
FIVE YEARS AGO DIDN'T GO FAR.
SO THAT IS A RESOLUTION THAT
THEY PASSED LIKE A HOPEFUL
RESOLUTION NOT ALONG QUICKLY BUT
ALSO SAID HIS LAN.
DOES GO FURTHER SO WHEN PEOPLE
ARE SAYING WE WANT WAY THE U.
HAS.
THAT'S INCORRECT WE WANT WERE
SEAT WHAT.
I'M HEARING PROPONENTS SAY HAS.
WE ACTUALLY ARE ASKING
CALIFORNIA DO MORE THAN THAT YOU
TO IT.
IS THAT CORRECT WERE WERE MOVING
WERE MOVING THE NEEDLE FORWARD
BUT WERE GIVEN THEM UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE SO.
YES THERE'S THIS GAPING HOLE
CALLED CHINA AND YOU KNOW THAT.
IF HE CONTINUES FOR EVER THEN
NOTHING IS GETTING DONE THAT'S
NEW SO THAT'S THE CUT OFF IS
TWENTY TWENTY THREE SO THIS BILL
I AND I'M SORRY TO DO THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
DISTURBING TO ME BECAUSE I IT
TOOK THIS BILL TO UNDERSTAND --
THAT MOST THE PRODUCTS I'M
PURCHASE SCENE LA AND THEY'VE
BEEN TESTED ON ANIMALS THAT'S
NOT TRUE BECAUSE I HAVE A GOOD
REFERENCE.
FOR BONDIES MAKE UP BOTH I'M SO
IT'S PROBABLY NOT TRUE HOWEVER
THAT THERE'S A POSSIBILITY THAT
THE BECAUSE MAKES I'M PURCHASING
HAVE BEEN TEST ON ANIMALS.
THE IF THE IMPRESSION GIVEN TO
ME BY THE ADVOCATES IS --
THAT THAT IS HAPPENING HERE.
SOMEWHERE RIGHT IN THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO PREVENT THAT WHICH I'M
ALL IN FAVOR.
I AM NOW HERE IN HERE AND I JUST
WANT.
AND VOTING FOR THIS TODAY I JUST
I THINK THESE ISSUES HOW WE'RE
NOT GETTING IT OFF THE FLOOR THE
ASSEMBLY WITHOUT THESE ISSUES
BEING ADDRESSED.
THAT'S MY FEELING RIGHT NOW.
AND IF YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT
WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY ABOUT
IS MOVING THE NEEDLE
SPECIFICALLY ME UP MOVING THE
NEEDLE ON TESTING IN CHINA.
THAT'S A DIFFERENT.
GOAL THAN I THOUGHT WE
ORIGINALLY AT IS THAT THAT IS
THE GOAL OF THIS LEGISLATION IS
NOT JUST.
THAT WE DON'T TEST HERE BUT THAT
WE GET THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT TO
CHANGE THEIR PRACTICES.
IS THAT CORRECT.
NO THAT THE THAT THE GOAL OF THE
LEGISLATION IS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN CALIFORNIANS.
BUYING COSMETICS AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS IF THEY HAVE
CONFIDENCE THAT THEY ARE CRUELTY
FREE.
AND SO YOU HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
KINDS OF TESTING YOU HAVE
TESTING.
BECAUSE OF CHINESE OR OTHER
REQUIREMENTS --
OR YOU HAVE INGREDIENT
INDIVIDUAL INGREDIENT.
AND SO THAT THAT COULD BE
HAPPENING --
FOR INGREDIENTS THAT GO INTO
COSMETICS HERE OR IN OTHER
COUNTRIES.
I JUST WANT TO ADD ONE THING WIN
WE PASSED THIS LAW IN CALIFORNIA
IT'S SAID THAT WE WANT TO END
THE ANIMAL TESTING FOR COSMETICS.
BUT WHAT IT ALSO SAID IS WHERE
THERE'S ALTERNATIVES.
THERE IS NOT ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM ON THAT SO THERE
REALLY IS NO GUARANTEE WE DON'T
KNOW WE DON'T HAVE THE LOOK
INSIDE THESE LABS TO KNOW THAT
THEY'RE USING ALTERNATIVES AND
THEY DON'T HAVE TO REPORT.
SO THIS LIKE SHE SAYS IF ITS
CRUELTY FREE WE WANT TO KNOW ITS
CRUELTY FREE.
AND THIS IS A WAY OF MOVING THAT
FORWARD FOR CALIFORNIA FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND PUTTING SOME
KIND OF DEADLINE ON THIS
INTERNATIONAL [inaudible]
KILLEEN TORTURING OTHER ANIMALS
THAT THEN [inaudible]
TEENS.
EVERYBODY'S MAKEUP ES DE LAWEDRE
SAYS ON THEIR WEBSITE CRUELTY
FREE BELOW IT'S NOT.
IF THEY'RE TESTING OVER IN CHINA
ON THE ANIMALS WHAT DIFFERENCE
DOES IT MAKE IF THEY'RE TESTING
AND CHINA ARE THEIR TESTING
CALIFORNIA THEIR TESTING ON
ANIMALS.
THEY HAVE NO RIGHT TO SAY ITS
CRUELTY FURRY.
SO WHAT WE'RE BUYING IS WERE
BUYING WHAT THEY WANT US TO
BELIEVE THAT'S NOT TRUE.
SO SO I'M JUST GONNA POST THIS
IS A HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION I
DON'T NEED AN ANSWER TO THIS BUT
I THINK IT'S VERY REALISTIC FOR
SOMEBODY LIKE ME WHO IS VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT PRODUCTS MADE IN
CHINA.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF THE LABOR.
CONDITIONS ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
RULES THAT ARE NOT FOLLOWED IN
CHINA I WOULD ALSO SUGGEST THAT
THE RULES THAT WE ASSUME ABOUT
PRODUCTS IN GENERAL.
THAT WE DO NOT WANT TO MOVE
COSMETIC MANUFACTURERS WHO STILL
EXIST IN THE UNITED STATES TO
CHINA I WOULD MUCH RATHER --
AND FEEL MUCH MORE COMFORTABLE
WITH AMERICAN MADE PRODUCTS THAT
I WOULD ON ANY CHINESE ME
PRODUCT I MEAN I'M I'M.
YOU KNOW SO BUT THEN WE MUST
WEEK WE MUST ASK OURSELVES IF
CHINA IS UNWILLING TO CHANGE THE
ROLES ARE WE IN FACT PUSHING
THESE MANUFACTURERS. TO CHINA SO
THAT THEY CAN AVOID THE TESTING
OF ANIMAL TESTING THAT'S
REQUIRED MY UNDERSTANDING IS IN
CHINA ONLY IF THINGS MADE.
OUTSIDE OF CHINA IF GOD I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S
WIENER SCENE LA.
AND THE THE UNKNOWN CONSEQUENCES
OF ACTUALLY MOVING WHERE WE HAVE
MORE PRODUCTS MADE IN CHINA DOES
NOT SEEM LIKE A AS OUTWARD GOAL
THAT WE WANT AND SO I'M JUST
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ACTUAL.
EFFECT OF THIS LEGISLATION NOT
THE INTENT BUT THE EFFECT OF
WHAT THIS LEGISLATION COULD MEAN.
AND IT WAS HYPOTHETICAL BUT YOU
CAN ANSWER WHAT IS ONE OF
ACTUALLY BRUCE WE CALL ATTENTION
TO THE SCIENCE BECAUSE WE
MONITOR CHINA AND WE ACTUALLY --
HAVE WE AND OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
HELP SUPPORT TRAINING OF
REGULATORS AND SCIENTISTS IN
CHINA --
THEIR INSTITUTE FOR IN VITRO
SIGNED BY HIM TO STOP YOU.
THERE BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT HEARING
WHAT MY GOD.
HEAR WHAT KIND OF TRAINING IS
BEING DONE IN CHINA I DO NOT
TRUSTS THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT'S
MANUFACTURER OR RULES I MEAN
TRYING IF I DO NOT WANT ANYTHING
MADE.
CURRENTLY MADE IN UNITED STATES
SENT TO CHINA ME PERIODS AND
CARE HOW WELL IT IS I DON'T WANT
IT SENT TO MEXICO TO BE MADE I
DON'T WANT TO SET CANADA BE ME I
WENT MADE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES.
SAU.
OKAY BUT BUT YOU STARTED
ANSWERING LIKE HOW WELL YOU
TRAIN THEIR REGULAR TO USE
ALTERNATIVE METHODS OKAY SO
WHERE JUST HOPEFUL THAT THEY
CHANGE THEIR LAWS.
AND THEY ARE IN THEIR MOVING
THAT WAY BUT WHEN WE WILL BUT
CALM THE MECCA OF CRUELTY FREE
THE JOBS WILL COME A YEAR I AM I
WAS ALSO.
PULLING OUT BECAUSE THEY KNOW
MYSTERIOUS ALSO HAD SOME
QUESTIONS ALONG THE SAME LINES
AGAIN I WANT TO KNOW TO THE
MISTRESS WAS SUPPORTING THE BILL
TO DATE SHE'S CONCERNED ABOUT
THE SAME ISSUES FROM WHAT I
UNDERSTAND.
SO I WOODS SAY TO THE AUTHOR
INTO THE SUPPORTERS --
WE MIGHT NEED TO CONTINUE HAVE
DISCUSSIONS BEFORE THIS IS TAKEN
UP ON THE FLOOR BUT WITHOUT IT
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION EGGMAN BETTER.
MAY RESPOND NOW YOUR QUESTION
I'M SORRY NOW BECAUSE WE'RE JUST
AND WE PROTECT MY PUBLIC TIME
TOO LONG AND AND MISTER BIGELOW
WAS.
GOT A QUESTION [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M WITH THAT AND THIS DOES
ENJOY A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
MISS GALGIANI ELECT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ARRIVAL.
NOT GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL
WITH MR PART VOTING NOW SO IT
DOES MOVE TO THE FLOOR
[inaudible]
MISTER CANNELLA
.
S. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE WHICH
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
YOU MAY PROCEED.
VETERANS CHAIR SP FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE PROVIDES EXPLICIT
AUTHORIZATION FOR COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS TO
INCLUDE CANNABIS CULTIVATION.
ALONGSIDE THEIR CROP REPORT
SUBMITTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE.
HIGHLIGHTING THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE CROP OTHER RELATED
PRODUCTION THAT INTO CROP
REPORTS WILL ENCOURAGE OUR
LICENSE GROWERS TO LEGITIMIZE
BECOME PERMITTED.
TAXPAYING BUSINESSES THE COST OF
THIS BILL TO THE STATE OR MINOR
AN OBSERVABLE AS MUCH IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS WE HAVE A
MOTION I MISS FRIEDMAN AND
SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
LASTLY THIS BILL SPONSORED BY
THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY.
IS SUPPORTED BY THE RULE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES THE CALIFORNIA
GROWERS ASSOCIATION.
AND MY FRIEND LOUIS SOLEIL NO --
SUPERVISOR FOR THE COUNTY
MONTEREY ASK [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND AG
INDICATES THAT ANY COSTS
RESULTING FROM THIS BILL WOULD
BE MODERN UNSORTABLE.
THINK I'M STILL STUCK ON MY
FRIEND LOUIS SLAY HOW NICE
TRYING TO PSYCH THAT CHANGE MY
BUT I AM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HE ASKED
ME TO CARRY THIS BILL SO I
WANTED. TO RECOGNIZE HIM SLASH
RELIABLE.
I GET OUT AND BE ROLL CALL WITH
MR OBERNOLTE BUT IN I THINK YOU.
ALRIGHT WE'RE A LITTLE SHORT OF
AUTHORS -- I
WILL ASK MISTER HERTZBERG MISTER
MCGUIRE MISTER MOORE LIKE MISTER
WELK MISTER WEINER MISTER ROTH
MISTER LARA AND MISSED SKINNER
WHO I SAW EARLIER.
I'M IN THE MEANTIME WE WILL READ
I HAVE A MOTION ON WILL READ THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BEFORE TAKE
MOTION.
ACR.
TO THIRTY FOUR S. B. ONE SEVENTY
FIVE ONE NINETY TWO TO SIXTY
NINE BY 326-397-62790 FIVE EIGHT
EIGHTEEN EIGHT NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE OR 490-991-2960.
797-297-7980 ONE NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN TEN TWENTY TWO TEN TWENTY
EIGHT TO THIRTY SIXTEEN THIRTY
NINE TO FORTY TO FIFTY ONE
TYPICALLY. 410-732-7810
801-110-1130 311-361-13711
531-165-1190 FIVE ELEVEN NINETY
SIX GLOBAL. 1-121-712-7412
811-283-1290 THREE THERE TO KNOW
FOR THEIR 238-135-51350
813-611-36513 SEVENTY FOUR
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE FOURTEEN
TEAM WITH AMENDMENT FOURTEEN
THIRTY FIVE FORTUNE.
421-482-1490 214-981-50315.
OH FOUR THIRTEEN OH FIVE IF YOU
KNOW NINE IN SCR.
NINETY ONE THERE WAS A MOTION BY
MISTER CALDERON A SECOND BY
MISTER BIGELOW IN THAT GETS OUT
ON A ROLL CALL.
MISTER WELK AND IT LOOKS LIKE.
YOU'RE GONNA PRESENT ON A
SUSPENSE FILE I KNOW YEAH A S.
B. OLDER TEEN FIFTY SIX ONLY.
ONE ONE MINUTE TWENTY SECONDS
LET'S GO OKAY.
THINKING THAT SHARON MEMBERS FOR
YOUR CAN FOR YOU SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX WHICH ALLOW
THE STATE TO MATCH PRIVATE
CONTRIBUTIONS UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN SUPPORT OF THE CALIFORNIA
AEROSPACE INSTITUTE THE
AEROSPACE INSTITUTE WOULD BE
CONSORTIUM OF THE STATE'S
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER LEARNING
NASUS ROCKET LAB AND THE PRIVATE
SECTOR TO BRING TOGETHER
INDUSTRY EXPERTS ACADEMIC AND
RESEARCH LEADERS IN ENGINEERING.
PHYSICS.
ANOTHER SCIENCE TO CONDUCT
GRADUATE AND POSTDOCTORAL
RESEARCH.
AEROSPACE IS A LARGER PART OF
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY THAT
AGRICULTURE IN FILM AND
TELEVISION COMBINED.
CALIFORNIA'S AEROSPACE DIRECTLY
SUPPLIES OVER HALF MILLION
MORTGAGE PAYING JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE AND IT WITH
THE INDUSTRY AVERAGE OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE INSTITUTE.
WOULD ALLOW CALIFORNIA TO BETTER
COMPETE WITH THE UNIVERSITY
TENNESSEE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN
AND THE UNIVERSITY OF ALABAMA
ENSURE THAT OUR BEST AND OUR
BRIGHTEST DAY HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THE INSTITUTE WOULD INITIALLY BE
HOUSE ON THE CAMPUS OF ANIL
VALLEY COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THIS LOCATION IS IN THE HEART OF
AEROSPACE VALLEY AND STUDENTS
WILL BE ABLE TO ACCESS ASSETS AT
MOJAVE SPACEPORT NASUS ROCKET
LAB EDWARDS AIRFORCE BASE.
IN THE PRIME AEROSPACE
MANUFACTURERS LOCATED ON
AIRFORCE PLANE FORTY TWO IN
PALMDALE THIS MODEST ALLOCATION
BE LEVERAGED TO BUILD UPON THE
FOUNDATION OF THIS ICONIC
CALIFORNIA INDUSTRY.
AND WITH THAT.
HOPE FOR YOUR SUPPORT HIM IN THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU THANK
YOU ARE THEIR SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
OPPONENTS DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCE ESTIMATES BILL COULD
CREATE ONE TIME PROP NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IF THESE FUNDS WERE TO BE BASED
UPON THE AMOUNT OF PRIVATE. OH
SORRY IF THESE FUNDS WERE TO BE
APPROPRIATED THE BILL REQUIRES
THAT THE FUNDING BE ALLOCATED TO
ANTELOPE VALLEY COLLEGE ON A
MATCHING BASIS BASED ON THE
AMOUNT OF PRIVATE CONTRIBUTIONS
THE COLLEGE HAS RECEIVED.
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE NOTES
THAT AS OF JULY TWENTY THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ANTELOPE VALLEY COLLEGE
HAS RECEIVED NO PRIVATE
CONTRIBUTIONS JUST IN SUPPORT OF
THE INSTITUTE.
THANK YOU.
AND SENATOR ALLEN WAS SUPPOSED
TO BE HERE BUT I JUMPED THE LINE
SO HE SUPPORTS THIS IS WELL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AT THAT BECAUSE TO SUSPENSE MISS
SKINNER.
SKINNER I KNOW YOU ARE ONLY
PRESENTING ON YOUR ACTUAL BILLS
YES I'M WAVING ON ALL THE
SUSPENSE UNITS.
ANDY I'M TWENTY SIX LATER WAS
NOT IT WAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I SEE A MOTION BY
MISTER CALDERON A SECOND BY MS
FREEMAN YOU ISOLATE I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND NEVER.
TALKED PASSED YES.
SUPPORTERS YES WHERE I JUST
ABOUT THE WAY THE WESTERN CENTER
ON LAW AND POVERTY A SPONSOR THE
BILL OR DRIVE A THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS ARE THEIR OPPONENTS
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THIS BILL RESULT OF UNKNOWN ONE
TIME COSTS THE POTENTIALLY UP TO
ONE MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE
AUTOMATION CHANGES TO THE
STATEWIDE AUTOMATED WELFARE
SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY UNKNOWN COST LIKELY
IN THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS MAY BE NECESSARY TO
FUNDED ADMINISTRATIVE MANUAL
WORKAROUND PRIOR TO COMPLETION
OF AUTOMATION CHANGES.
BECAUSE THE BUDGET ALLOCATE ALL
AVAILABLE FEDERAL TEMPORARY
ASSISTANCE FOR NEEDY FAMILIES
BLOCK GRANT FUNDS ANY INCREASE
COSTS RESULTING FROM THIS BILL
WOULD BE BORNE ENTIRELY BY THE
GENERAL FUND.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE SUPPORT
PROTECT CAL WORKS AND CAL FIRST
PARTICIPANTS WOULD THE BILL DOES.
THANK ECONOMY ROLL CALL THANK
YOU.
SKINNER S. B. TEN EIGHTY FIVE
ENJOYS IT YOU PASS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY A DOCTOR QUIRK A
SECOND BY MISTER CALDERON YOU
MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU ARM WAS MY FOLKS GET
TO THE TABLE THIS IS TO PROTECT
OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES WHO ALSO
HAVE UNION DUTIES.
AND TO ENSURE THAT THEY CAN
PERFORM THOSE DUTIES STYLE ALLOW
THE SUPPORTERS TO SPEAK.
THANK YOU MICHELLE CAST OF THE
SERVICE IN PLACEMAT SHOW UNION
THIS IS A COMMON PRACTICE THAT'S
NEGOTIABLE CALIFORNIA HOWEVER
WITH SOME EMPLOYERS TO DENY IT.
WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW IS THAT
THE BILL EXPLICITLY REQUIRES THE
UNION. TO REIMBURSE THE EMPLOYER
FOR ALL COMPENSATION PAID TO THE
EMPLOYEE WHILE THEY'RE ON THEIR
LEAVE OF ABSENCE THAT INCLUDES
ALL WAGES ALL BENEFITS.
EVERYTHING --
SO WE THINK THIS BILL COMMON
PRACTICE AND COST NEUTRAL.
AND ADDITIONALLY THE BILL COVERS
ANY LIABILITY AND HOLDS
EMPLOYERS --
HARMLESS INDEMNIFY SIR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRPERSON
BROWN OF CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DOROTHY JOHNSON OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
WHAT WE DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO NEGOTIATE
REIMBURSEMENT --
THERE ARE ADDITIONAL COSTS THAT
AGENCIES WILL INCUR SUCH AS THE
QUICHE AND TIMES SICK LEAVE
PENSION BENEFITS ALL WHICH ARE
BORNE BY THE EMPLOYER.
ADDITIONALLY THERE ARE COSTS FOR
THE COLLATERAL OR TEMPORARY
EMPLOYEES THAT NEED TO COME ON
BOARD TO REPLACE INDIVIDUALS
WHEN THEY ARE GRANTED LEAVE AND
FOR THESE REASONS WE DO OPPOSE
THE BILL THANK YOU.
CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE DON'T
GIVE US FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
LIKE -- LA
MY COMMENTS WERE THAT IF THE
COUNTIES THANK.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT RESULTS POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT I'M BUDGET GENERAL
FUND COSTS MARY'S ON A
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATE
PROGRAM WITH A NUMBER.
TO POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS
AND SORT OF MONTHS THIS
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS.
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
WITH THE ASSAULT THAT CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ON OUR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES CALIFORNIA OBVIOUSLY
WANTS TO CONTINUE TO BE A MODEL
OF PROTECTING PUBLIC EMPLOYEES
AND THEIR ROLE FOR THEIR
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING RIGHTS.
I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU THINK IT'S HAD ON OF
THE ROLL CALL.
FINALLY HAVE SP.
TWELVE HUNDRED WE ARE MOTION BY
DOCTOR QUIRK A SECOND BY MISS
FRIEDMAN.
THANKS SO MUCH THE BILL HAS BEEN
NARROWED.
AND IT'S OBVIOUS IN THE ANALYSIS
HOW IT WAS AND I'VE CALIFORNIA
WAS THE FIRST STATE --
TO ENACT THESE GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS A VERY
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR FAMILIES TO
HELP PREVENT GUN VIOLENCE ASK
YOUR SUPPORT ME HAVE SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
SUPPORTERS.
HI AMANDA WILCOX HERE ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS OF THE
BRADY CAMPAIGN TO PREVENT GUN
VIOLENCE --
I WILL LIMIT MY REMARKS TO THE
FISCAL ISSUE --
ONE OF THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL IS TO WEIGH THE FILING AND
SERVICE FEE FOR THOSE SEEKING A
COMBINES RESTRAINING ORDER THIS
WAIVER IS SIMILAR TO THE FEE
WAIVERS THAT CURRENTLY EXISTS.
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS AND I THINK
WE CAN ALL AGREE THAT WE DON'T
WANT THIS LEGAL TOOL TO DISARM
SOMEONE DANGEROUS ONLY AVAILABLE
TO PEOPLE HAVE THE MONEY.
OUGHT TO PETITION FOR THE ORDER --
BUT I ALSO ADD THAT THE ORDER
HAS NOT BEEN USED MUCH.
A IN PART BECAUSE THE LAW WHEN
ENACTED STATED THAT THIS SHOULD
BE A LAST RESORT IF THERE'S
ANOTHER WAY TO REMOVE THE
FIREARMS.
THAT SHOULD BE USED FIRST --
AND WE'RE FINDING THAT PRIMARILY
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS USING THIS
TOOL AND OF COURSE THEY'RE NOT
GONNA CHARGE THEMSELVES A FEE
WHEN THEY ARE --
ISSUED AN EMERGENCY ORDER --
AND THEN OF COURSE ANY FEE IS
OFFSET BY THE OTHER COST TO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM A
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM TO COMMUNITIES
OF WHEN THEY'RE A SHOOTING DOES
HAPPEN IF THAT CAN BE AVOIDED --
THAT SAVE MONEY COSTS AND OF
COURSE THE MORAL COSTS AND I
KNOW THAT.
THE PRICE LOSING SOMEONE TO
GUNFIRE --
THE OTHER THING I WANT TO
MENTION THAT WASN'T COVERED BY
THE ANALYSIS IS THE REQUIREMENT
FOR COURTS. TO SUBMIT --
THE INFORMATION TO THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE THAT THE GUNS
HAVE INDEED BE RICH THEN
RELINQUISHED --
IF THOSE RECORDS TO NOT GET TO
DOJ THEN THE INDIVIDUAL SUBJECT
TO THE ORDER WILL FALL INTO THAT
ARE PROHIBITED PERSON SYSTEM
FILE.
AND IT'S BEEN COVERED MANY TIMES
IN THIS BUILDING THE PROBLEMS
WITH THAT SYSTEM IN TERMS OF
BRINGING DOWN THE BACKLOG AND
THE COST OF OPERATING THE APPS
PROGRAM SO WE CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT NAMES.
IN APPS THAT SHOULD NOT BE
BECAUSE RELINQUISH SO I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE A FILE ON THIS
MEASURE.
ALRIGHT WHICH ARE CLOSE.
THAT'S REALLY VOTE THAT GETS OUT
ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I SNUCK IN THERE.
SEC RARICK.
WORK WHERE MOVING QUICKLY TODAY.
AND YOU ARE ONLY GOING TO
PRESENT ON YOUR YOU PASS CORRECT.
S. B. TEN OH SEVEN DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO CLARIFY THE
DEFINITION OF BUILDING SUPPLIES
AND MATERIALS.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK
WE HAVE A SECOND BY MISS
FRIEDMAN YOU MAY PROCEED.
S. ROWBOAT.
THANK YOUNG SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT ATTACKS
AND HE ADMINISTRATION IS
ESTIMATED THAT EACH QUALIFYING
CENTER CONSTRUCTED WILL CREATE
ONE TIME STATE AND LOCAL REVENUE
LOSS OF TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN
THOUSAND INCLUDING A HUNDRED SIX
THOUSAND UP FROM THE GENERAL
FUND.
I THINK YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF STRIVE
VOTE THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THIS PRESENTATION OF THE
DAY.
YEAH.
SP TEN SEVENTY SIX DO PASS AS
AMENDED MAKE THE BILL'S
REQUIREMENTS APPLY TO THE STATE
HAZARD MITIGATION PLAN INSTEAD
THE STATE STATE EMERGENCY PLAN.
WE A MOTION BY AT MISTER BIGELOW
AT SECOND BY DOCTOR QUIRK WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PROCEED.
I AS FOR AN AYE VOTE TO STERN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THINK SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICE
ESTIMATES THE COST TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL ARE MINOR AND THAT
GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
S. B. TWO ALL THIRTY NINE ENJOYS
A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE
A MOTION AND BY MISTER ABOUT SIR
BIGELOW A SECOND BY A DOCTOR
QUIRK WOULD YOU LIKE TO PROCEED.
A AS FOR A NIGHT VOTE THIS IS
MODERNIZING THE CALLUSES SYSTEM
UPDATE OF THE MEASURE WOULD
[inaudible]
A RECENTLY.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
OF IT TIFFANY MARK ON BEHALF OF
THE SECRETARY STATE WOULD
PROBABLY SPONSORED THE BILL.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCES NEUTRON THIS BILL.
THAT GETS OUT ON ANY WROCLAW
THANK YOU MENTIONED THAT THINK
YOU YELTSIN'S SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOR THE GOLD STAR PRESENTATIONS
OF THE DAY.
MISTER MCGUIRE YOU'VE SIGNED UP
NEXT SORRY MR MARKKULA KEEP
PASSING YOU BY.
IT'S NOT INTENTIONAL.
IT IS INTENTIONAL BUT I'M GOING
BY THE LIST.
MISTER MCGUIRE SORRY SP SIX
SIXTY EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVEN'T MOTION BY DOCTOR
QUIRK A SECOND.
BY MISS EIGHT MEN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PROCEED THANK YOU SO MUCH OF
THE VERY QUICK THE CURRENT FINE
STRUCTURE IN PLACE FOR
VIOLATIONS OF THE COMMERCIAL P.
LIES ON ENOUGH TO DETER
OFFENDERS.
PARTICULARLY REPEAT OFFENDERS
WHO TAKE A LOOK AT ISSUES THAT
OF CROSS CONTAMINATION THAT LEAD
TO SEVERE ILLNESS AND DEATH OF
ANIMALS.
ON THE LANGUAGE IN THIS BILL AS
RECOMMENDED BY THE FEET
INSPECTION ADVISORY BOARD TO CT
A FAINT TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND
ENFORCE THE NO ACTION WAS TAKEN
WOULD HAVE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SPORT IDEA
TO SELL THE ONLY BE HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA GRAIN AND FEED
ASSOCIATION PACIFIC COAST
RENDERING ASSOCIATIONS.
HOME AS AS OF THE SENATOR
MENTIONED THIS WENT THROUGH THE
FEED ADVISORY BOARD WHICH IS A
BECAUSE I DEDUCE A QUASI
GOVERNMENTAL ENTITY THAT ADVISES
THE SECRETARY --
IT IT THEY GO THROUGH THE BUDGET --
ARE INTENDED --
TO ADDRESS BAD ACTORS JUST
ANOTHER SOME CONCERN THAT THE
PENALTIES ARE ARE HIGH THEY'RE
SIGNIFICANT.
IT WE HAVE A COMMITMENT AND AND
THE FEW DIVISOR COMMITTEE HAS A
COMMITMENT FROM CDFA.
THAT THEY WILL PUT A MATRIX IN
REGULATION AFTER DRAFT
REGULATION HAS THAT WILL --
PROVIDE.
THE DEGRADATION OF OF THE
PENALTIES SO YOU'LL HAVE YOU
KNOW A PAPERWORK PENALTIES WILL
BE TWO FIFTY WELL IF YOU.
HURT OTHER ANIMALS IT WOULD BE.
YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANTLY MORE ALSO
THEY'LL STILL HAVE THE UP TO FOR
AN OBESE NOTICE OF VIOLATION
SOME OTHER THINGS SO THEY ARE
GOING TO DO REGULATIONS.
THAT WILL FURTHER --
DELINEATE.
THAT THE PENALTIES AND I KNOW
THAT HAS BEEN A CONCERN AND SO
WE WANT TO BRING THAT FORWARD IN
THAT THAT THE INDUSTRY DOES
SUPPORT THIS THANK YOU.
THINK YOU'RE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS [inaudible]
OPPONENTS.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCES NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT GETS OUT WITH THE
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING EXCEPT
MISTER GALLAGHER VOTING I THINK
YOU MUST REQUIRE.
I S. B..
SEVEN FIFTY NINE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK A SECOND
BY MISS EGGMAN WHICH I PROCEED.
EXHORT SPEND CHAIR A LONG STORY
SHORT IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
OVER TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
RESIDENTS I DID NOT HAVE THEIR
VOTES COUNTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
IF HE SAID AND TO DENY CREATES A
PROCESS FOR LOCAL ELECTION
OFFICIALS ARE NOTIFIED VOTERS
WHEN THEY'RE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS INJURE MISMATCHES TO ONE
OF THE FILE. TO BE ABLE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT BALLOT WOULD
COUNT AS THIS ENJOY SUPPORT FROM
SECTOR SAY TOUGH SOMEONE SAY
THANK YOU OUT FOR ALL OF THEIR
WORK IN PARTNERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU. TO FREMONT COMEY HALF
THE SECRETARY OF STATE PROUD TO
SPONSOR THIS BILL.
GREAT I ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
AND THE CHILD ON BEHALF OF THE
ACLU OF CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
SECRETARY OF STATE ANTICIPATED
NO FISCAL IMPACT AS A RESULT OF
THE RESULT OF THIS BILL HOVER
FINANCE KNOWS THAT THIS BOOK
CREATES A REIMBURSABLE MANDATE.
TO MODIFY CERTAIN PRECINCT FOR
REQUIREMENTS AND PROCEDURES
RELATING TO THE VERIFICATION OF
SIGNATURES ON A VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT.
THANK YOU.
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER MCGUIRE.
S. B..
EIGHT THIRTY THREE I BELIEVE IS
THE NEXT.
ONE CORRECT WE HAVE IN MOTION BY
DOCTOR QUIRK A SECOND BY A
MISTER BIGELOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PROCEED THE SWITCHMAN SERIOUS
FEET THIRTY THREE WILL CREATE
STATEWIDE EMERGENCY EVACUATION
OR GUIDELINES IN TRAINING FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY.
AND I'LL SHARE WITH YOU JUST
PERSONALLY I HOW DEFICIT IN
THESE WILDFIRES HAVE BEEN
PROTECTING THE NORTH BAY AREA OR
SEEN THE CAR FIRE AND AS WE SAW
THE THOMAS SCIENCE IN A BARBARA
COUNTY.
I ENDED WOODS THIS --
WE'VE AMENDED IT TO BE TO REDUCE
FISCAL COSTS BY ALLOWING A WAY
AS TO MAKE IT SECURE CANS
COMPLAINTS THE GUIDELINES
CONDITION FOR RECEIVING
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT PERFORMANCE
GRANTS AND FUNDING.
SPEAKERS ITS PART.
YES I CAN MEDICARE RUSSELL NO
ACT ON BEHALF.
WHEN YOU HAVE STATE OF FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICTS SOLICITATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL CREATES A PATHWAY FOR
UNIFORM?
AND AND CRUCIAL --
ALERT FOR BOTH --
A CITIZENS AND FIRST RESPONDERS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
OF MICROBES NOT BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CARE ALSO BEHALF
THE CITIES OF SANTA ROSA
GLENDALE THE MARIN COUNTY
COUNCIL MAYORS AND COUNCIL
MEMBERS IN CINEMA COUNTY ALL
SPORTS.
CHRIS CONRAD PRESIDING SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
FINANCE NOTES A NUMBER TO
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST TO
TO THE REQUIREMENT THAT THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
PROVIDE THE PERSON ALL OF ITS
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT OFFICE
WITHIN A COUNTY WITH TRAINING ON
THE FEDERAL WIRELESS EMERGENCY
ACT SYSTEM.
THINK IF THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL.
MOVING ON S. B..
NINE STAY FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I'VE A MOTION BY
DR QUIRK A SECOND BY
[inaudible]
MISTER BIGELOW.
WHICH I PROCEED BECAUSE I WAS
READING CHAIRS HAVE WHICH IS A
REFERRAL ASSESSMENT OF ONE
DOLLAR PER HEAD ON CATTLE
SPECIFICALLY FOR CANCER RESEARCH.
I AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I DON'T.
SUPPORTERS ADJUSTABLE FEEL THE
CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION JUST ONE QUICK
COMMENT --
THE BILL DOES NOT ACTUALLY
AUTHORIZED TO FEED AUTHORIZES
PRODUCERS TO VOTE TO ESTABLISH
THE FEE AND IF THEY DO
ESTABLISHMENT FULLY REFUNDABLE.
BRIGITTE UP THANK YOU THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
JASON BRIGHT AB HAVE WESTERN AYE
DURING AND WE ARE SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
IS THERE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
CNN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ESTIMATES ONE TIME
COST OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONGOING
ANNUAL COST OF TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR
ADMINISTRATION AND OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITIES RELATED TO THE
COUNCIL.
ADDITIONALLY FINANCE NOTES AT
THIS BILL REQUIRES PROPONENTS TO
DEPOSIT FUNDS FOR THE
DEPARTMENTS COST TO CONDUCT
INITIAL IMPLEMENTATION
REFERENDUM VOTE.
THANK YOU --
THAT GETS OUT UNDER A ROLL CALL
WITH MR FUNG NOT VOTING.
I BELIEVE THAT'S IT MISS.
GIVE ONE MORE LOOK AT ONE MORE
TEN TWENTY NINE MEANS.
I'M SORRY WHICH FELL.
BUT SB TEN TWENTY TEN TWENTY
NINE THE BILL'S GOING TO
SUSPENSE.
YES -- SO
YOU WOULD DAY YOU'RE SAYING YOU
THINK A FIFTEEN MINUTE BREAK I'M
KIDDING AS SOLELY ABSOLUTELY.
PAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY EFFORT
AYE VOTE AT APPROPRIATE TIMES.
TENANTS HERE.
I FEEL LIKE THE LOOK.
JUST YOU NOW GIVE IT TO YOU VIA.
PRESENTED --
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUICK PRESENTATION MAKE USE OF
MUCH ROOM THANK YOU MISTER
MORLOCK.
MISTER MARTIN I DID YOU COME TO
PRESENT ON A SUSPENSE ITEM.
IRATE YOU MAY PROCEED S. B..
SIX FIFTY SIX I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT HERE I GO MY MADAM
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS I S. B.
SIX FIFTY IT'S YOUR RIGHT TO
PRESENT IT'S MY RIGHT TO GIVE
YOU HELL.
LET'S NOT CHANGE ANYTHING.
S. B. SIX FIVE SIX ADDRESSES A
UNIQUE FORMULA CONCERNED IN THE
JUDGE'S RETIREMENT SYSTEM.
TO WHICH WAS ESTABLISHED IN
NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
THE FORMULA IS A HYBRID DEFINED
CONTRIBUTION AND DEFINED BENEFIT
PENSION PLAN.
SO TWENTY FOUR YEARS LATER WE'RE
OBSERVING IT DEFICIENCIES THAT
NEED TO BE CORRECTED THE STATE
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGES ARE THE
ONLY CALIFORNIA JOB
CLASSIFICATION IN SUCH A PLAN AS
FAR AS I AM AWARE OF WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING THE PAST TWO YEARS
TO ADD A MINOR.
TAB MINOR AMENDMENTS TO THE PLAN
WHILE MINIMIZING COST TO THE
JUDICIARY BRANCH.
I CERTAINLY ORANGE COUNTY PLAY
RETIREMENT SYSTEM BOARD FOR
TWELVE YEARS AND AM VERY FOCUSED
ON FAIR AND SUSTAINABLE.
PENSION BENEFITS AND RETIREMENT
BENEFITS ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
DETERMINED THAT THE ACTUAL REAL
COST IS TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS AMORTIZED OVER TWENTY
YEARS.
I BELIEVE THE MORALE BOOST IN
THE PREDICTED PRODUCTIVITY THAT
WILL RESULT FROM IT THESE
MODIFICATIONS WILL BE MORE THAN.
OFFSETTING THAT THE COST WILL BE
IN CALIFORNIA IT'S RESIDENTS.
AND THE TWENTY ONE MILLION IS A
VERY LIBERAL CALCULATION WITH
THE ACTUAL COST ANTICIPATED TO
BE LOWER.
WE DO THE TAXPAYERS SUPPORT
SERVICE BY WATCHING A JUDGE
CONTINUE TO SERVE ON THE BENCH
WHILE IN DURING CHEMO TREATMENT
IN ORDER TO ATTAIN THE REQUISITE
NUMBER OF YEARS SERVICE IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT.
A SPOUSE RECEIVES A RETIREMENT
INCOME SHOULD THE TREATMENT
PROVED TO BE UNSUCCESSFUL.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT.
J. ARREST TO IS STRONGLY FUNDED
AND GOVERNOR BROWN HAS APPOINTED
NUMEROUS JUDGES WHO DESERVE
FAIRNESS IN THEIR COMPENSATION
PACKAGES.
I'LL GET TO SPLIT MY WITNESSES
GET TO SPECIFICS BUT MADAM CHAIR
S. B. SIX FIVE SIX HAS RECEIVED
THE TITLE OF THE JUDICIAL
FAIRNESS ACT TWENTY EIGHTEEN FOR
A REASON.
THE AWKWARD NINE INCENTIVES IN
THE CURRENT STRUCTURE SHOULD BE
REMEDIED THIS BILL A SPARE IT
IMPROVE MORALE AND IT TREATS
JUDGES IN A SIMILAR MANNER AS
THE BARGAINING GROUPS THEY WORK
WITH.
ADVERTISING TWENTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS OVER TWENTY YEARS IS A
SMALL STIPEND THAT WILL RETURN
DIVIDENDS IN MULTIPLES AND RICK
CROONING AND RETAINING JUDGES.
I HAVE WORKED CLOSELY WITH
CALPERS AND HAVE TAKEN THEIR
AMENDMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS
SENATOR RICARDO LARA IS A JOINT
AUTHOR N. ASSEMBLYMEMBERS BRO IN
COOLEY OUR PRINCIPAL COAUTHORS
AND CINNAMON CALDERON IS A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
I RECEIVED SOME EIGHT HUNDRED
SIGNATURES FROM JUDGES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IN SUPPORT AND IT IS MY REQUEST
THE S. B. SIX FIFTY SIX BE
REMOVED FROM SUSPENSE AT THE
EARLIEST TIME CONVENIENTLY
POSSIBLE AND BROUGHT TO THE
ASSEMBLY FOR HER APPROVAL.
LET ME ALLOW MY TWO WITNESSES TO
PROVIDE JUDICIAL LOTS OF VACANT
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING I'LL BE VERY BRIEF
MY NAME IS LAURIE DAMN WELL AND
I'M A NEW JUDGE AT THE
SACRAMENTO SUPERIOR COURT I'M
I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING NOT ON
BEHALF OF THE SACRAMENTO
SUPERIOR COURT OR ANY PARTICULAR
ORGANIZATION.
BUT RATHER AS AN INDIVIDUAL
JUDGE SEEING THIS THROUGH THE
PRISM OF MY OWN EXPERIENCE AS A
MOTHER AS A WIFE AS A PERSON
COMMITTED TO SERVING IN PUBLIC
SIERRA SERVICE FOR YEARS TO COME.
I FEEL PRIVILEGED HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED JUST LAST YEAR AND I
SINCERELY HOPE THAT I HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE AS A JUDGE
FOR AT LEAST THE NEXT TWENTY
FIVE PLUS YEARS.
BUT I ALSO KNOW THAT THINGS
HAPPEN AND SOMETIMES IT JUST
DOESN'T WORK THE WAY WE PLAN AND
THIS BILL ADDRESSES THAT REALITY --
CONSIDER FOR EXAMPLE JUDGE STEVE
PARK FROM ORANGE COUNTY WHO WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH PANCREATIC CANCER
AT AGE SIXTY THREE AFTER
NINETEEN YEARS OF SERVICE.
DOCTORS GAVE HIM FOUR TO SIX
MONTHS TO LIVE UNFORTUNATELY
THEY WERE WRONG BUT AT THE TIME
HE KNEW HE HAD TO SURVIVE TO THE
AGE OF SIXTY FIVE TO GET A
DEFINED BENEFIT FOR HIS WIFE.
A DISABILITY RETIREMENT WAS
WORTH ABOUT A THIRD OF THE
DEFINED BENEFIT PAYOUT HE HAD
BEEN COUNTING ON FOR HIS
FAMILY'S FINANCIAL SECURITY.
AS IT WAS HE WISE IT S. B. SIX
FIVE SIX WHERE THE LA HE COULD
HAVE LAUGHED WHEN HE REACHED
TWENTY YEARS OF SERVICE IN
ASSURING HIS WIFE OF FINANCIAL
SECURITY.
AS IT IS HE PUT IN NEARLY A FULL
YEAR IN EL HEALTH AFTER HIS
TWENTY YEAR ANNIVERSARY IS A
JUDGE JUST TO AVOID LEAVING
HIMSELF AND HIS WIFE WITH LESS
THAN HALF OF THE DEFINED BENEFIT
THEY WERE COUNTING ON THIS IS
NOT THE ONLY JUDGE WHO SUFFERED
FROM THIS.
TYPE OF EXPERIENCE AND IT COULD
HAPPEN TO ANYONE --
AS A NEWLY APPOINTED JUDGE I'M
AWARE I'M AS WELL OF A NUMBER OF
WELL QUALIFIED LAWYERS MY FORMER
PEERS WHO SEE THIS LACK OF
SECURITY IS AN IMPEDIMENT TO
PURSUING A JUDGESHIP.
PARTICULARLY BECAUSE YOU DON'T
SEE THIS TYPE OF CLIFF VESTING
IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR OR EVEN IN
THE PUBLIC SECTOR --
THIS AS YOU'VE HEARD THIS
LEGISLATION IS A VERY MODEST
FIXED THAT WOULD HAVE A PROFOUND
IMPACT ON THE LIVES OF MY
COLLEAGUES OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL
DECADES IN WITHOUT AND FOR THAT
REASON I RESPECTFULLY.
REQUEST YOUR ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
A MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I
CAN'T HAMLIN I'M A JUDGE OF THE
FRESNO SUPERIOR COURT FOR
NINETEEN AND A HALF YEARS.
AND A DIRECTOR OF THE ALLIANCE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES SPONSOR FOR
THIS BILL --
I APPRECIATE YOUR GIVING US A
CHANCE TO SPEAKABOUT THIS BILL
I HAVE JUST ONE MORE TRAGIC
EXAMPLE WOULD GIVE TO YOU.
APPALLED BOARDMAN A JUDGING
TULARE COUNTY POINTED AT AGE
FIFTY NINE PUT IN TEN YEARS
DIAGNOSED WITH CANCER TERMINAL
CANCER --
SPENT THE LAST YEAR ON THE BENCH
IN.
LIKE PRESERVING.
CARE SO THAT HE COULD REACH HIS
RETIREMENT AGE.
AND NOT DENIED HIS WIFE A DECENT
RETIREMENT.
I HE DIED FORTY ONE DAYS AFTER
HE RETIRED --
THAT WAS AN IMPACT ON THIS COURT
ON THE PEOPLE THAT COUNTY.
AND A TRAGEDY AS FAR AS HE AND
HIS WIFE WONDERING IF HE WAS
GOING TO BE LEFT.
VIRTUALLY PENNILESS --
LEADING A DAY OR DYING A DAY
BEFORE HE REACHED SEVENTY WOULD
HAVE COST MORE THAN HALF O
THEIR PENSION.
AND WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
KINGS RICHES HERE SHE'S LOOKING
AT SOMETHING LESS THAN SIXTY
THOUSAND A YEAR BECAUSE HE MADE
IT TO THE FINISH LINE.
WE WOULD HAVE LEFT THAT WOMAN
WITH LESS THAN THIRTY THOUSAND A
YEAR MARRIED TO HIM FOR FORTY
PLUS YEARS THIS IS A MAN WHO.
HAS GIVEN A LOT AND THERE'S NO
REASON THERE'S NO PUBLIC POLICY
REASON FOR JUDGES TO FACE THAT
KIND OF HARDSHIP.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THEIR
SPOUSES AND SURVIVORS WHO DEPEND
ON THEM --
THIS BILL IS AS THE SENATOR
POINTED OUT AS OVERWHELMING.
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IT'S A VERY
SMALL PRICE FOR A SMALL FIX.
THAT HELPS TO ADDRESS THE WORST
ASPECTS OF THIS BILL WE ARE NOT
ASKING.
FOR A WHOLE LOT OF IMPROVEMENT
IN THE SENSE OF GETTING OUT
EARLY EXTRA PAY NOTHING --
THE CALPERS HAS HAD OPINED
VIOLATE PEPPER IN THAT IT DOES
NOT.
PROVIDE ANY ENHANCEMENT ANY
EXISTING BENEFIT.
NO JUDGE GETS A DOLLAR MORE NO
JUDGE GETS A DOLLAR A DAY SOONER.
THAN IT THAT JUDGE STATE ON THE
BENCH TO RETIREMENT.
I URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORTERS.
GOOD MORNING LANCE ITO LOS
ANGELES SUPERIOR COURT RETIRED
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHN ADAMS JUDGE OF THE ORANGE
COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
THERESA CANEPA JUDGE OF CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JUDGE ELIZABETH FLIP IT OF LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU IT'S NOT OFTEN WE HAVE
FAMOUS JUDGES IN OUR
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WAS
KIND OF COOL.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCE IS OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT INCREASES THE
COST THE JUDGES RETIRE. TWO
MEMBERS PENSION BENEFITS WHICH
IN TURN INCREASES THE STATE%
[inaudible]
ABILITY.
THANK YOU THIS BILL DOES GO TO
SUSPENSE I AM LOVE THE
PRESENTATION I I WOULD HAVE
SPENT A LIFETIME BEFORE THIS
WORKING TOWARDS ENSURING --
SECURE RETIREMENTS FOR ALL
WORKERS AND I WOULD NOTE THAT --
YOU KNOW WE FIGHT REALLY HARD TO
KEEP PENSIONS FOR A TRASH TRUCK
DRIVERS WHO --
HOPE TO RETIRE WITH TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR PENSION
AND YOU KNOW SO.
I JUST WANT TO BRING THAT UP AS
I THERE ARE WORKERS WHO WORK
THEIR ENTIRE LIFE AND WOULD HOPE
TO ONLY PRESERVATIVE XIN THAT
WAS LESS THAN THIRTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS I UNDERSTAND.
PEOPLE LIVE IT LEVELS BUT I'M
HEADED KNOW THAT FROM MY A
REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUE AND FROM
ORANGE COUNTY THAT THIS IS A
PART OF A BROADER CONVERSATION
ABOUT HELPING THANK YOU THIS
DOES GET MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE.
AND WE HAVE WORKED DILIGENTLY
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS TO TRY
AND BUILD SOME FAIRNESS.
TO EVERY EVERY BARGAINING GROUPS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER WEINER.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING ON SP TWO
TWO ONE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND BY MISS
CARILLO.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND BY MISTER
GARCIA THANK YOU YOU MAY PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AYE MADAM
CHAIR I COLLEAGUES ON AS THE TWO
TWO ONE IS VERY SIMPLE --
AT THE COW PALACE OF STATE
FAIRGROUNDS SITTING ON THE
BORDER OF DALY CITY IN SAN
FRANCISCO --
THERE ARE --
GUN SHOWS --
NUMEROUS TIMES A YEAR --
WE HAVE --
UNANIMOUS --
LOCAL.
SUPPORT FROM THE SAN FRANCISCO
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS CEMETERY
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS DALY
CITY COUNCIL MULTIPLE SCHOOL
DISTRICT PEOPLE WANT THESE GUN
SHOWS GONE --
AND THIS BILL WILL --
WILL AND THEM IV FISCAL IMPACTS --
TO THE CAL PALACE --
WILL BE SMALL IN THE KIND BUDGET
AND THEY WILL ABSOLUTELY BE ABLE
TO GET ALTERNATIVE SHOWS OR
EVENTS TO COME AND TO FILL A GAP.
ALRIGHT SO I RESPECTFULLY ON
BEHALF OF MY DISTRICT --
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MADISON Y.
ON BEHALF OF SAN MATEO COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
IN THE INTERESTS OF TIME WHAT
THE SENATOR SAID DATA BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS GREATLY APPRECIATE.
THAT AIM OF THE BILL TO GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNING BOARDS OF THE
ABILITY TO MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT
THE SHOW IS BEING HELD IN THEIR
COMMUNITY AND WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AIBO [inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
WITH CHAU YOUR ENTRY ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
NOW I'M SORRY I DO THAT OFTEN
AYE BRUISES TO PROVE IT
[inaudible]
I'M HANDICAPPED.
THANK YOU AYE CAPULET REPRESENT
CROSSROADS OF THE WEST GUN SHOWS --
WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL WE WORKED ON THE
ORIGINAL A STATUTE WITH SENATOR
CORBETT AND IT WE HAVE MODEL.
NATIONAL LEGISLATION REGULATING
GUN SHOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DOES LICENSE THEM AND
THERE'S A REVENUE --
SITUATION THERE --
THERE A MODEL FOR FOR THE WHOLE
NATION THE THESE ARE STATE
FACILITIES WERE TALKING ABOUT
AND THERE ARE VENDOR CONTRACTS
IN PLACE THEY'VE BEEN THERE FOR
OVER TWENTY YEARS WITH NO
INCIDENT.
LAW ENFORCEMENT --
IN THE PAST HAS VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED HAVING THE SHOWS
THERE TO PREVENT UNDERGROUND
SALES THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE LOSS TO THE FACILITY --
IT'S OVER 25% OF THE GENERATES
AN A CALL FOR THEM TO GET.
VENDORS TO COME INTO THE COW
PALACE TO DO THE CONDITION OF
THE FACILITY.
THERE WILL BE A LOSS OF STATE
AND LOCAL SALES TAX THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL.
RECENTLY.
THAT ALLOWS THE SALES TAX TO BE
UTILIZED --
PARTIALLY FOR THE FOR THE FAIR
STATEWIDE SO THIS ACTUALLY GOES
IMPACT ON ALL THE FAIR STATEWIDE
BECAUSE OF THE REVENUE GOES INTO
A POOL. TO BENEFIT ALL THE FAIRS
THE BE ALL LOS ANOTHER FAIRS
WILL BE IMPACTED.
TENNIS ALSO CREATES NEW CRIMES
WITH FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU TO TIONAL OPPOSITION.
MANAGER ROY GRIFFITH --
MY COLLEAGUE MADE ALL THE GOOD
POINTS WE NEED TO MAKE LOVE TO
SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION GUNNER'S A
CALIFORNIA IN THE HONORARY WERE
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
THINK.
THANK YOU ADDITION OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LARA NO
INTELLIGENT ON BEHALF OF WESTERN
FAIRS ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
THIS WILL COST THE CALVET.
THAT'S IT THANK YOU.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
FINANCE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S A CONFUSING
PRESIDENT AT THE STATE LEVEL BY
STATUTORILY PROHIBITING THE SALE
OF FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION IN
ONE DISTRICT AGRICULTURAL
ASSOCIATION.
WILL NOT PROHIBITING THIS
ACTIVITY AT OTHER DISTRICT
AGRICULTURAL ASSOCIATIONS.
THANK YOU --
SEE NO COMMENTS REJECT CLOSE --
I'VE THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THAT GETS OUT OF THE ROLL CALL
THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER YOU
HAVE ONE MORE IT LOOKS LIKE SB --
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT.
I YES ARE.
MOUNTED THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
SP SEVEN SIXTY FIVE IS --
CLEAN UP IN CLARIFICATION
LEGISLATION RELATING.
TO S. B. THIRTY FIVE FROM LAST
YEAR BILL OUT THERE TO
STREAMLINE HOUSING PRODUCTION
ODD WE HAVE WORKED OUT VERY HARD
ON THIS BILL AND I WORKED WITH
THE OPPONENTS OF THE BILL AND I
WITHOUT SPEAKING FREDDIE.
ONE A MUCH BROADER CONSENSUS --
JUST TO MAKE SURE EVERYTHING IS
VERY CLEAR ON S. B. THIRTY FIVE
STREAMLINING AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK --
FOR NINE MOVED BY MISTER GARCIA
I'M IN A SECOND THAT --
IS THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
OR NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU WHICH LIKE CLOTHES
RESPECT WEST BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S OUT OF THE ROLL CALL WITH
MISTER GALLAGHER NOT VOTING AND
MYSTERIOUS VOTING NOW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ROGER.
I'M SORRY THAT WAS I AM MISS
REYES.
NOT VOTING ABOUT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR ROTH.
ARE YOU HERE TO PRESENT ON A
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
SURE I HAVE TO BILLS --
SP TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT MEDICAL
RECORDS RETENTION ACT AND SENATE
BILL TEN TEN EIGHTY SEVEN WHICH
IS A PACE CLEANUP BILL.
OKAY THESE ARE BOTH GOING TO
SUSPEND THEM.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU YOU.
YOU MAY PROCEED WE'RE OF ANY
PARTICULAR BILL FIRST.
BACK PLEDGE.
HOPE SPRINGS ETERNAL YES MA'AM.
CLAIMANT YOUR MEMBERS --
SENATE BILL TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT
WHICH IS THE MEDICAL RECORDS
RETENTION ACT BILL.
IS DESIGNED TO ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
RETRIEVE AND PRESERVE THEIR
MEDICAL RECORDS PRIOR TO
DESTRUCTION IF THEY DECIDE TO DO
SO -- AS YOU
KNOW OF THE BILL PASSED OUT OF
THE SIMPLY HEALTH OF MY
COMMITMENT.
TO ADDRESS SOME REMAINING ISSUES
RATE RAISED BY THE COMMITTEE
CHAIR DOCTOR WOULD.
I IT IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE HEALTH COMMITTEE HAS SOME
AMENDMENTS THAT I HAVE NOT YET
SEEN BUT HAVE AGREED.
TO BASICALLY IN CONCEPT AND I
WILL LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING.
WITH THE HEALTH COMMITTEE AND
THIS COMMITTEE --
TO TRY TO EVENTUALLY MOVE THIS
BILL OFF OF SUSPENSE.
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU ARE THERE AND SUPPORTERS.
OPPONENTS RESTART AGAIN MEDICAL
BOARD OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED POSITION ON
THIS BILL WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON THIS
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A NEED URBAN ON THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION --
WE'RE OPPOSED TO S. B. YEAR
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT LOS AMENDED
TO REMOVE THE SECOND NOTICE THAT
WE THINK IS A MASSIVE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN AND WILL
INCREASE COST PRESSURES ON THE
PROVISION OF CARE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA --
WE DO WANT TO SAY THAT WE
APPRECIATE ONGOING STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSIONS ON THE BELL --
UNFORTUNATELY IT SEEMS LIKE
THOSE HAVE BROKEN DOWN BASED ON
THE LAST AS THATOF AMENDMENTS
WE HAVE SEEN SO WE RESPECTFULLY
ASK THEOLDEST ON SUSPENSE AT
THAT TIME.
THINK THANK YOU DO YOU SEE THE
SENATE AMENDMENTS FROM HEALTH
TODAY.
OKAY I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WERE
WORKING WITH THE SAME BILL.
AT ANY OTHER OPPOSITION SEEN
NONE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION AND TO SPEAK
NATIONAL WORKLOAD COST TO
IMPLEMENT THIS BILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
INDICATES THAT ANY COSTS
RESULTING FROM THIS BILL ARE
MINOR AND OBSERVABLE WITHIN
EXISTING RESOURCES.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
ANY FISCAL IMPACTS.
THANK YOU AND THAT'LL BE MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE FILE WOULD YOU.
LIKE TO PRESENT ON THEN S. B.
TWELVE THIRTY EIGHT IT LOOKS
LIKE.
A TEN EIGHTY SEVEN MINIATURE.
SORRY TEN EIGHTY SEVEN THE APACE
BILL.
THIS --
MEDICARE MEMBERS THIS A PROPOSES
SOME WHAT WE THINK ARE IMPORTANT
CLEAN UP PROVISIONS SO LAST
YEAR'S PACE MEASURES THAT WERE
PASSED THE AT THE END OF SESSION
AS I RECALL --
JUST TO HIGHLIGHT SOME OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT PROVIDED TO
STAFF TO REDUCE THE FISCAL
IMPACT OF THE BILL WE'VE
SUBMITTED AMENDMENTS TO REDUCE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS
OVERSIGHT COST TO RESTORE
RESPONDED THE PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
REQUEST.
BY STRIKING SOME OF VAGUE
LANGUAGE HAVING TO DO WITH
SERIOUS VIOLATIONS AND INSERTING
A SPECIFIC REFERENCE. TO
VIOLATIONS OF THE FINANCIAL CODE --
WE'VE ALSO SUBMITTED TO
AMENDMENTS TO OPPOSE OF REMOVE
THE OPPOSITION OF WHY GREEN ONE
OF THE PROGRAM ADMINISTRATORS
THAT PREVIOUSLY OPPOSED THE BILL.
I'M CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON SOME
ISSUES OF RECENTLY --
IDENTIFIED --
RIP THE BILL REMAIN SUPPORTED BY
VARIOUS CONSUMER GROUPS AND
OTHERS AND I AGREE SPECULATE
REQUEST YOUR FAVORABLE
CONSIDERATION --
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK
YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
KAREN MEMBERS MIGHT BELOW FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ESCROW
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA MORTGAGE
ASSOCIATION PACE IS A GOOD
PROGRAM BUT THESE ARE SENSIBLE
IMPROVEMENTS THAT WILL HELP
PROTECT CONSUMERS WE ASK FOR AND
I THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE BOARD
IN SUPPORT.
AND A BUCK ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
WE HAVEN'T HAD A CHANCE TO LOOK
AT THE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD --
SEEM -- TO
CHANGE SOME OF THE PROVISIONS OF
THE BILL BUT BASED OFF OF THE
SIX TWELVE OF VERSION WE ARE
OPPOSED BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN IT
COSTS THAT ARE NOT INCLUDED IN
THE MINISTRATIONS CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN.
SPECIFICALLY ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT WOULD
REQUIRE TO IT'S TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR.
AND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING FOR
ONE ATTORNEY THREE TO REVIEW A
PROCESS REQUESTS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYTHING ELSE SIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU GENEROSA.
AND I KNOW CENTER LARS ON HIS
WAY -- IN SO
IN THE MEANTIME WE ARE GOING TO
READ THE BILLS THAT WILL BE
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE FILE AS HE
APPROACHES WILL DO THIS QUICKLY.
OKAY THAT'S RIGHT WE'RE GONNA
JUST READ THE BILL'S GOING TO
SUSPENSE --
SAN ART THAT'S OKAY SURE SORRY
WAS DEBATING THAT THE ENVY AND
JAY LACK.
BILLS THE SUSPENSE SB
254-061-4022 372-742-75320
340-334-06390.
NINE FORTY FIVE BY THEIR NINE
BUT THE ONE BY 776-356-56700
777-267-82780 379-282-3820
682-882-9830. 834-881-8959.
FIVE NO NO 691-891-9949 THIRTY
NINE THIRTY THREE NINE THIRTY
SEVEN PLAN 449-559-7960 NINE
SIXTY ONE NIGHT 649-669-6897.
397-497-8949 NINETY ONE THOUSAND
WHAT OF THEM TINT OR FORTUNE OR
810-101-0132. 1-421-721-9220 ONE
TO TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY FOURTH
JUNE. 252-262-2910.
FORTY ONCE HE SAID 210-772-83280
610-872-9411 HUNDRED LEBANON.
FOR ELEVEN TWELVE THEM FIFTEEN
ELEVEN NINETEEN ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE OF THEM 251-126-1130.
ELEVEN THIRTY ONE OF THEM A
THIRTY TWO OF THEM AT THIRTY
EIGHT THEM FORTY FOUR THAT A
FORTY EIGHT THEM.
FIFTY ONE THEM FIFTY SIX THE
ASSEMBLY TO THAT ASSEMBLY.
778-111-8611 NINETY ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT TO ABOUT
325-214-1220 322-522-81230 EIGHT
TOWARD FIFTY FIVE TOOK SIXTY TWO
OR 631-254-1250. EIGHT TWELVE
SEVEN TWO TO A 791-300-1301
THIRTEEN A 313-101-31113.
TWELVE
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THIRTEEN
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT THIRTY
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY THREE NINE
THIRTEEN FORTY THREE THIRTEEN
FORTY SEVEN THIRTEEN FIFTY SIX
THIRTEEN SIXTY THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THIRTEEN SIXTY NINE
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX THIRTEEN
EIGHTY SEVEN THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
THIRTEEN NINETY SIX THIRTEEN
NI YOU.
KNOW TO PUT YOU KNOW SIX WHAT
YOU KNOW NINE POINT.
213-142-11430 FOURTEEN THIRTY
FOUR FOURTEEN THIRTY SEVEN
FOURTEEN FORTY FOURTEEN FORTY
SIX FOURTEEN FORTY SEVEN
FOURTEEN FORTY EIGHT FOURTEEN
FORTY NINE FOURTEEN FIFTY FIVE
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR FOURTEEN
SIXTY FIVE FOURTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
TO SEVENTY FOUR POINT TWO FIFTY
SEVEN FORTUNE. 811-483-1480.
SEVEN DEGENERATE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY --
THOSE ARE ALL THE BILLS THAT ARE
MADE TO THE SUSPENSE FIVE ONE I
THINK ON THE SENATORS WHO WAVED
PRESENTATION ON THOSE BILLS
HOWEVER IF YOU ARE HERE TO
REGISTER SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO A BILL THAT WAS MOVED TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE --
WHERE PRESENTATION WAS WAIVED
AFTER US IN OUR LARA PRIEST THAT
FINISHES UP HIS PRESENTATIONS
YOU MAY I'M COMPORTS REGISTER
THAT'S PART OPPOSITION BUT
WITHOUT WE WILL GO ON TO SENATOR
LARA THANK YOU?
AFTER WAITING S. B. THIRTY IT
ENJOYS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
I HAVE A MOTION BY --
MISS CARILLO AND A SECOND BY
MISTER MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS S. B.
THIRTY ESTABLISHES A WORKING
GROUP TO RECOMMEND POLICIES THAT
USE MARKET MECHANISMS TO INVEST
IN NATURAL FOR STRUCTURE TO
REDUCE.
THE RISK OF RELATED ARE CLIMATE
CHANGE THIS IS REALLY A NEW WAY
OF THINKING ABOUT INSURANCE AND
WORKING --
WORKING GROUP IS THE PERFECT
PLACE TO MAKE POLICY
RECOMMENDATIONS INSURANCE
COMPANIES AS YOU KNOW ARE
EXPERTS AT RISK ASSESSMENT AND
CAN BE IMPORTANT PARTNERING
CLIMATE POLICY.
AS ROUGHLY AS FOR AYE VOTES.
THANK YOU ARE THERE'RE SUPPORTER
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
THANK YOU MY NAME IS LOUIS
BLUMBERG AND THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CLIMATE CHANGE
PROGRAM FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY.
WE HAVE IN A PILOT PROJECT IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
KNOW POTENTIALLY UNDER THIS BILL
UNDER WAY IN MEXICO LOOKING AT
THE CORAL REEF.
ALONG THE COAST OF CANCUN WE
THINK THIS --
THIS PROJECT IS IS BEING.
HER PARTNER SWISS RE ON THIS AND
WE THINK WE CAN.
DO THE SAME KIND OF PROJECTS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THAT CAN
REDUCE CLIMATE RISK BY
PROTECTING NATURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
A CENTER LARA HAS CRAFTED A VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND SIMPLE AND
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL --
AND WE AGREED THAT THE THE
POTENTIAL.
SURE IT'S INDUSTRY TO ADDRESS
CLIMATE CHANGE IS CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE LAWS AND POLICIES --
AND WILL HELP CALIFORNIA PREPARE
FOR CLIMATE CHANGE WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU DISCUSS PORTER.
CATERPILLAR BUT AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION OR PLEASED
TO SUPPORT THIS BILL OUR MEMBERS
ARE DOING A LOT OF THAT IN THE
INNOVATIVE THINGS ACROSS THE
WORLD AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING WHAT WE CAN BRING IN THE
CALIFORNIA.
KRIS CONNOR PRESENT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WALLACE IS A NEUTRAL ON THIS
BILL.
THANK YOU THAT GETS OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MR FUNG NOT BUT A
MISTER GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
MR LEARN WHICH YOU I GUESS
YOU'RE THE LAST BELL OF THE DAY --
S. B. SIX NINETY ONE YOU MAY
PROCEED WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS --
CARILLO IN A SECOND BY MISTRESS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I SP SPA
SICKLY ONE EXPLICITLY INCLUDES
IMMIGRATION STATUS OF THE
PROTECTED CLASS UNDER OUR
CALIFORNIA.
EQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION ACT
THIS MEANS THAT ALL PERSONS IN
THE HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTION
ARE ENTITLED TO EQUAL RIGHTS AND
FREEDOM FROM DISCRIMINATION ON
THE BASIS.
OF THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR THANK
YOU SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES REPRESENT
IN THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE
OF EDUCATION WHILE WE DO NOT
HAVE HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WE DO HAVE STUDENTS
WHO ATTEND --
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAMS AT
HIGHER INSTITUTIONS AND I LIKE A
SOME OTHER ALLEY AND LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES WE ALSO HAVE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE OPERATED ON
THE CAMPUSES OF INS HIGHER
INSTITUTIONS.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
THE BILL AND WE ALSO SUPPORT THE
ANALYSIS RECOGNIZING THAT
THERE'S NO FISCAL IMPACT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU JUST SAW SUPPORTERS.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
REPORTS IT IS IS NOT ANTICIPATED
FISCAL IMPACT ASSOCIATED WITH
THIS BILL.
OUR FINANCES AND ANTICIPATED
STILL WOULD CREATE COST
PRESSURES AT THIS UC'S OR THE
CAP CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT IS OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL
THE MEDIA CENTER LARA MEMBERS.
AT THIS POINT IF ANYONE THE
AUDIENCE WISHES TO SPEAK ON A
ITEM THAT WAS MADE TO THE
SUSPENSE FILE WEARS WAY PLEASE
COME TO THE MICROPHONE STATE
YOUR NAME ON THE BILL AND I HAVE
VERY SHORT COMMENTS IF ANY IN.
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION --
DAVID NEVIN ON BEHALF OF THIS
SANTA MONICA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT AND LOS ANGELES
COMMUNICATIVE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
FOURTEEN SIX THINK IT IS ALSO
HELPFUL OF YOU --
FOR THE FUTURE STATE THE
AUTHOR'S NAME YOU DON'T HAVE TO
ADJUST SPAIN.
MADAM CHAIR TONY TO CARE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWO SEVEN FIVE
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO WE'VE HAD
MULTIPLE MEETINGS WITH THE
SPONSORS AND STAFF FROM THE
AUTHORS OFFICE.
URINALYSIS ACCURATELY PUT
REFLECTS OUR CONCERNS THAT THIS
SHOULD BE A REGULATIONS ONLY
BILL AND ALL REFERENCES TO
FUNDING TREATMENT SERVICES
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE BILL
BECOME SOFT SUSPENSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
THANK HIM.
HELEN ROTH DOWDEN TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS ALSO IN OPPOSITION
TO THE CURRENT VERSION OF S. B.
TWO SEVEN FIVE PORTANTINO.
WE THINK IT SHOULD BE NARROWED
TO JUST ADDRESS TREATMENT SINCE
THE EXPERT PANEL IS REALLY ABOUT
TREATMENT AND WHILE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF OF TREATMENT
STANDARDS.
WE DON'T THINK THE BILL SHOULD
ADDRESS AND OF THANK YOU.
THERESA BURKE FITCH --
I'LL TRY TO MAKE THIS BRIEF BUT
I HAVE QUITE A FEW.
SP AT NINE SIXTY SIX SENATOR
WIENER --
ONS SUPPORT. FOR SERIES ALAMEDA
COUNTY WASTE MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY AND HEAL THE BAY SP
TEN SEVENTEEN ALLEN --
CLEAN SEIZE LOBBING COALITION
AND SUPPORT AS SPEED TEN FORTY
ONE THEY'VE AYE.
THEM.
IN OUR FOR THE NATIONAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY TWO LEYVA NOW
TO RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND
SUPPORT [inaudible]
SORRY -- S.
B. TWELVE SIXTY THREE PORTANTINO
ON THE HAVE THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBING COALITION AND KILL THE
BABY AND SUPPORT --
S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY FIVE ON
BEHALF OF CLANCY'S LA I MEAN
COALITION KILL THE BAY AND
SUPPORT.
S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
STERN ON BEHALF OF CERES AND
SPORTS.
VIDEO OF ONE REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES
ORGANIZATION I CONCUR WITH THAT
COMMENTS OF MY PREVIOUS OF THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS ON SP.
TWO SEVENTY FIVE OUGHT WE ARE
OPPOSED AS THE BILL IS CURRENTLY
IN PRINT.
MARY LEE SHRIDER DIRECTOR OF
RIGHT TO LIFE OF KERN COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB THREE TWENTY BY
SENATOR LEYVA.
A THERE IS NO NEED TO DUPLICATE
ALREADY AVAILABLE CERTAIN
MEDICAL SERVICES THE BILL'S LONG
TERM COSTS ARE STILL
UNDETERMINED AND IT'S FUNDING
MECHANISM IS VAGUE.
A SAFETY AND UNIVERSITY
LIABILITY CONCERNS HAVE THUS FAR
BEEN ADEQUATELY ADDRESSED AND
THE BOTTOM LINE IS IF A STUDENT
NEEDS A RIDE TO PICK UP HER FREE
ABORTION PILLS --
THAN AN OVERPASS WILL GET HER
WHERE SHE NEEDS TO GO PROTECT
UNIVERSITY AGAINST LIABILITY
COSTS AND CERTAINLY --
BE MORE COST OF SPARES THINK YOU.
MY NAME IS RICKY SILVER AND I'M
HERE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
THREE TWENTY BY CENTER LEYVA --
COLLEGE CAMPUSES SHOULD BE
PLACES FOR LEARNING AND
KNOWLEDGE CHILD KILLING.
AND THE OF THERE IS STILL A
LOOPHOLE IN THE BILL.
THAT THE SENATOR HAS YET TO FEEL
WHICH HAS HAS YET TO FIX SORRY.
A WHICH WOULD POTENTIALLY RACE
ARM -- THE
TUITION FEES OF STUDENTS LIKE
MYSELF WHO ARE OPPOSED.
TO ABORTION TO TO HAVE TO PAY
FOR THOSE KINDS OF THE THINGS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY ENEMIES ON THE FIRMS FOR AND
FOR LIFE AT SAN JOSE STATE
UNIVERSITY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB --
THREE TWENTY AND PROTECTION OF
OUR CONSCIENCE RATES AND THE
HEALTH OF ALL MY FEMALE PEERS ON
CAMPUS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY.
HI JENNY ISSUE FROM BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA AND I ASK FOR YOUR
OPPOSITION ON SB THREE TWENTY
THANK YOU.
MY HOPE SAID FLORES ON BEHALF OF
THE NEWMAN CATHOLIC CENTER AT
SACRAMENTO STATE AND THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
AND WE ARE IN A POSITION OF SPT.
TWENTY PLEASE READ ARAMBULA IN
THE STUDENT AFFAIRS SEE IN
OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE TWENTY GREG BROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL ALSO
IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE TWENTY THIS IS NOT A COST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO DEAL WITH THIS
ISSUE OF COLLEGES ARE ALREADY.
PRESSURED WITH TUITION INCREASES.
THIS IS GOING TO BE PUSHED ON TO
THEM STUDENT FEES ARE GOING TO
BE INCREASED THERE'S ALREADY
PRIVATE SECTOR THAT IS ALREADY
PROVIDING THE SERVICES THIS IS
JUST THE PHARMACEUTICAL
COMPANIES AND THE ABORTION
INDUSTRY TRYING TO GET.
ON CAMPUS BECAUSE THE LOWER THE
COST THE LOWER THEIR OVERHEAD IT
WILL ALSO.
PUT THEM IN DIRECT ACCESS TO THE
PEOPLE TRYING TO SELL TO AND SO.
PLEASE --
THIS CAN BE SOLVED BY UBER
VOUCHERS YOU --
STAND AND DIRECT OPPOSITION
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE HAVE
HEARD THANK YOU WE'VE HEARD --
MULTIPLE PEOPLE NOW WITH AS
OPPOSED TO THREE TWENTY AT THIS
POINT -- IF
YOU ARE SPEAKING ON S. B. THREE
TWENTY PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AND YOUR OPPOSITION AND AND THAT
IS IT WE USUALLY ALLOW TWO
SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES EACH WE
HAVE.
ALREADY --
EXCEEDED BACKS ARE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TERESA MARZANO
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIANS FOR
LIFE IN OPPOSITION TO TWO THREE
TWENTY LEYVA.
CRISTINA HER ON BEHALF OF
STUDENTS FOR LIFE OF AMERICA IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE TWENTY BROOKE PIES SENIOR
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON AND ON
BEHALF OF OUR STUDENTS WHO I'VE
SPOKEN TO AND ARE CSU PRESIDENTS
WE URGE YOU TO OPPOSE SB.
THREE TWENTY GOOD MORNING
LINDEMANN I'M A REGISTERED NURSE
AND SPEAKING IN OPPOSITION HIS
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY THANK
YOU.
AND BRAVE DENY UNITED METHODIST
WOMAN SPRICHT SPEAKING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION.
TO THREE TWENTY RALPH MORE
LOUDLY MEMBER ST ROSE CATHOLIC
PARISH SOUTH SACRAMENTO.
AND IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO SB
THROUGHOUT.
THREE TWENTY THEY NAVA MEMBER OF
THE WOMAN'S POLICY INSTITUTE A
CO SPONSOR OF SB THREE TWENTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
STEVE PATTEN ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR
FOR FAMILY AND RESPECT LIFE
MINISTRIES FOR THE DIS EASE OF
SACRAMENTO --
EXPRESSING OPPOSITION TO SB.
THREE TWENTY CAN LESS AND WITH
THECALIFORNIA COAST FOR YOUTH
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE ONE EIGHT
SENATOR WIENER.
PAMELA GIVES A GOOD AFTERNOON
AND GOOD MORNING AGAIN --
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA
GIVES REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
EIGHTEEN A SENATOR WIENER.
AND ALSO S. B. NINE THIRTY THREE
SENATOR ALLEN THANK YOU.
PARDEE PLACENCIA I'M FROM A
BIGGER AMERICA OFFERING A AND
I'M STRONG OPPOSITION TO SP.
THREE MADAM CHAIR ROB ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN DIEGO
FISHMAN'S WORKING GROUP AND THE
CALIFORNIA FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD
INSTITUTE.
IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
TEN SEVENTEEN THANK YOU AND I
THINK THAT CONCLUDES OUR PUBLIC
COMMENT PORTION AND THAT
CONCLUDES OUR APPROPRIATIONS
HEARING.
TODAY --
MEETING ADJOURNED